Gentlemen.
We're a little lie.
Yeah, Dude. Steve, old ladies and
gentlemen, Prime Room in the house.
A steevo preparing himself for his long
stretch in the pokey from mockings.
Seaworld openly, uh, on top
of a very dangerous sign.
Do there's a video of you,
you were streaming live while you,
you fucked with the seaworld sign.
I had two different ones. I had the
highway sign where I change it to say see,
road sucks. And then there's the one where
I climbed up the 150 foot tall crane.
Okay. I think both of them made
me shit, my pants. One of them.
We were watching it. Brian and I were
watching it and my toes were curling.
I know you're watching it
live. Lifting up. Yeah.
We were watching your wife when
were in see rod when you are,
I mean San Diego and you were doing the
sign one climbing up the sign and he
kept on calling my head.
Yeah. Oh Dude. Yeah.
How did you live in and out,
man, that was seem our fall.
That was like appropriate. It was right
there down in San Diego, near seaworld.
The highway science said seaworld drive
and I had changed it to say seaworld
sucks and like I said,
it was appropriate.
My crane one was completely fucking
idiotic. There is a, it's like, okay,
let me protests. Seaworld and
some random construction site.
Nowhere fucking near sea world,
you know,
let me fucking bring an
inflatable killer whale,
like a toy whale client up 150 foot
crane when you're 150 feet up in the air,
nobody, no one's going to be able to
see your fucking toy whale, you know,
so done with that. Dot. Right.
Steven won A. Dot. I never knew.
They know vendor could even tell him side.
By the time I get up there,
I got 80 firefighters, 18 cops,
a helicopter and a swat team.
I'm like,
that stuff is,
if something real was going down
and they had put all the resources,
trust me, I get it. That's
why I'm going to jail.
How long are you going to jail?
I have a 30 day sentence,
but I don't think I'll like,
I have done that.
I think the automatically cut it in half
and then maybe even get out quicker.
How does that work? I didn't
necessarily have to go to jail at all.
Like I asked my,
I had my lawyer to get me jail time
specifically because my fucking cranes.
Dot was so idiotic. Ah. I was
like, man, I gotta go to jail.
That would be the only one tiny little
part of it. That makes any sense at all.
Because like if you're trying to make
a statement about captivity, right.
You know, put yourself and kept,
right. That's the whole deal.
So I asked for it and, and um, so you
asked for jail, like you could do that.
I'm sure I could. I could have done like
community service, like a, you know,
whatever. Like I was like, Nah,
dude, because I'm a fucking
intention hoard. So like,
I'm like, dude, like, like scrubbing
graffiti. That's not a cool story.
Like going to jail. That's a headline.
You know, like, I'm going to get fucking,
I'm gonna, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna get, you know,
Steve was going to jail. That's
a fucking, that's newsworthy.
So ridiculous. Yeah. Welcome to my world.
Did you say that to the dough to the judge
never even had to go to court because
they all, they all worked it out.
So when they kept postponing my,
my arraignment and when uh,
the way, you know everybody,
by the time that the prosecutor and
my lawyer finally worked out a deal,
then when the arraignment was
back on and they said, hey,
we reached a deal and then
they close it all down
in the jail before.
Sure.
I've got,
I've got the fucking most
hilarious criminal record
ever did like was the first
time, the first time, uh,
I was like 16 or 17 they go to high
school in England and just got nailed with
some weed chill and another country.
Oh,
I've been to jail in like five countries,
five but I've been see Canada,
England, America, Sweden,
and I'm not counting Mexico because
that was more of a catch and release,
fly fishing.
Right.
Would it happened in Cancun,
Mexico? Ah, it was like, I was, uh,
you know, like blacking
out on special k, you know,
like ketamine and I was like
climbing on this roof. And like,
I kinda like fell off of it
and, and uh, I don't know.
They just grabbed me and detained
me. Oh yeah. The, I mean,
I wasn't like, uh, yeah, but it, but it
was pretty scary. I mean, it was like,
it was a legit, when you're in, when
you're in Mexico, like that's fucked me.
I fucked up. You can vanish. Yeah.
Like a lot of people vanished.
Chapo God,
no.
Apparently they were closing in on him
and he fell and broke his leg and he was
carried off by his guards. Wow.
Apparently labor, their clothes,
they keep closing in on him. Right. But
that's a good, a good disappeared for the,
for that guy. He's psyched.
It disappeared. Most
people disappear in Mexico.
Totally not cycle.
That's a very good point.
People vanished in Mexico.
Like those students,
like the 43 students that were
murdered, it's just scary shit. Right.
So when you were in Mexico, when you
were, would you sober up in jail?
Did you like realize what
had happened now? Like a man,
I don't know. I mean, I guess like
a, it all just kind of worked out.
Like it wasn't, it wasn't a big deal,
you know. Um, they, they let me go,
but, uh, they just kicked
Joe. Yeah. In Sweden.
I was in like properly in jail for
fucking five days for international drug
smuggling. Rich bring in, well, what
I did, I was videotaping it and uh,
um, I was in Norway and I put a
bunch of weed and do a condom.
I tied it and I'm not, and
swallowed it, choked on it.
And I was like puking up blood
trying to get it out. Like,
so then I flew from Norway to
Sweden so that it would, you know,
put it on video, go. Yeah,
totally. And then like put it
on the Internet. Well, yeah,
I mean later, you know, but um,
so how'd the Swat Swat it in Norway
and got an airplane to Sweden, so that,
so that way I'm crossing
international lines, you know,
to qualify as an international
drug smuggler. Then when
I got to Sweden, you know,
I had my, in my, I was promoting my tour
every interview. Like there they say like,
Oh yeah, how you doing? And listen, I'm
man, I think I might die of intestinal,
the strangulation because I swallowed
this big package of drugs and it won't
come out. You know, cause it took days,
it didn't come out for like six and a
half days. So the says so every like,
like a reporter, like read the,
read the article or whatever it was.
And the cops were at the newspaper and
so then they, they, they, they, uh,
they arrested me like after
I shit it out. And, um,
and they took me to the jail
and, and um, you know, they got,
they brought me into the,
from the jail to the hospital,
put me in this like cat scan machine,
which revealed they said a
foreign object in my body.
It's still don't know what that was. And,
uh, they kept me in a cell for five days,
shitting into a plastic bag,
fucking digging through my shit.
Yeah. And like, and then, and
then after five days in there,
they brought me back to the
hospital for another like scan.
And it showed that like the foreign object
had only moved like three centimeters,
like my body. So like
they're like, oh fuck it.
And they just had me pay a pay a fine
and go, you don't even know what it is.
I don't know. I don't know.
They said it was like a
key. Now I don't know. They said it
was a sharp and I dunno, like sharp.
Yeah, they, I don't, I really
don't know what it was. Maybe
there'd be bullshitting,
but that might be still,
it's been over 10 years.
Did you ever get yourself looked
at again? No. My friend Rosie,
I didn't, I didn't even
really care that much. But uh,
yeah, Sweden, I was wild man.
And again,
I was super psyched because I knew I was
on that little scrolling fucking thing
on CNN at the body. He's leading less
sites for that. Well, yeah, I mean I,
I thought I made,
because we can now.
Then when they brought me to the
station initially, like they've,
they've put my backpack on the
table and they reach into it,
like the first pocket they reach
into the first and they pulled out,
it was a fucking ecstasy pill,
like with the fucking
head and it had a print,
like an imprint of a smiley face on it,
you know?
And I didn't even remember it
being in there. I'm like, fuck,
I didn't know that was in
there. And then I thought, man,
maybe I'll be in Sweden for a while.
But uh,
it turns out that the ecstasy
wasn't even like that. You know,
they weren't even that been
out of shape over Brexit. See,
they're more pissed about weed over
there. Really? Yeah. I don't know why.
Just because we things well,
because we'd like a,
they think it makes you lazy,
I think. And they're not cool.
That's how it is in Asia. Why? I
think, you know, they're like this,
that makes you lazy and,
and we're not fucking lazy people and
so they didn't want to really punish me
for that really frustrates me. That,
that stereotype with weed making me lazy.
That drives me crazy. That is the one
that drives me the most nuts. You're lazy.
You're lazy. Does not make you
fucking lazy. It just doesn't,
I'm not lazy. It drives me nuts. I
was never lazy man. When I was loaded.
No. My longest time in jail, uh,
wigging out. Like I guy I was,
I was in La County jail for five days.
One time I got arrested for felony
obscenity and a principal to second degree
battery in Louisiana. Yeah. Because it
was like I was doing my oldest show.
What does that mean? Principle too? It
means that I arranged like an assault.
What the fuck happened?
Well,
what happened was like I was
doing my old show and um,
you know, part of it, it was, I was
chugging out of a Tequila bottle,
like throughout the whole thing.
And I'd like, you know, whatever,
like I had the Tequila bottle at the
edge of the stage and um, you know,
some kid like climbed on the stage
and grabbed the bottle and I see these
bouncers come over and just neutralize it.
And I'm like, damn, these guys are good.
These fucking bouncers are
our pro. So I, as I said,
who wants to get on this stage and try
to run from one side of the stage to the
other past the bouncers,
you know,W is British bulldog.
We'll play British bulldog dog and
these guys were going to fuck you up.
So there's like one kid who is like the
bony little skinny little 19 year old
kid was like jumping up and down,
like pointing at himself that he was
just so did he wanted it so bad and I
couldn't, like I had to pick him.
So I picked this kid and he ran.
He just ran, you know, I'm videoing it
myself. I said, one, two, three, go.
The kid like runs halfway across
the stage and they just grabbed me.
It was totally anticlimactic.
And these three like football player,
the college football player bouncers,
like they just lifted him up like in
unison, like over their heads and legs,
just like the kid on his head on the
stone. And he was like twitching and,
and like, you know, they think they're,
the police reports said he was bleeding
out of an ear or something like,
and odd and it was really fucked up.
You know,
they do that when they knew that he was
going to run across be, I don't know,
I never said slam him on his head,
you know, I, I'd said that fuck. Um,
but uh, but yeah, and so like he knew
in my mind I'm thinking, oh, I do,
this is such a lawsuit. Like this is, this
is bad, you know, so you're not thinking,
oh my God,
this poor kids
that to legal fees that too. But
like what a, whatever it was.
He was just all bad, you know, it was
all bad. And in my head, like the mantra,
the show must go on, like pretend it's
not bad and just continue. So I'm like,
I was like fuck on the video. And
somebody in the crowd was, was uh,
had a home video camera rolling on.
I mean this is like, what was it,
2002, so like, I mean,
this is before they had cameras on cell
phones and someone's got like a fucking,
like, VHS home video camera
and um, on, on the tape,
which they turned over, they
were like, that's a crimes.
You've turned it over to the cops or
they escapes the newspaper and the
newspaper gave it to the cops.
So on the thing, I'm like,
that kids be loaded into an ambulance
plugin who wants to play another round and
we actually pulled it off.
No, I know it was bad.
Did anybody sign up for route?
I can't remember. I can't,
can't remember if we did.
We did or not, but, but uh,
[inaudible] salt though,
honestly it was principal to
second degree battery or whatever.
I think that's how I think I have
it right. And like they, you know,
that that was a crime but,
but by the people like watch this video,
they really were upset with,
with Steevo.
And so there was another point
in the video where I stayed,
I use an industrial staple gun to
staple my ball sack to my leg and shit.
Right. And, uh, so I've got,
I'm covered in blood too, like,
because like part of the
other part of the show,
I break a light bulb over my head and
like pick up like a piece of the broken
glass and like,
like literally slash my tongue because
the tongue like bleed so much and it
heals really fast. I just bleed all over
my sophos Izmir blood everywhere and,
and so I'm covered in blood
and I've, I've, I've got my,
my Dick and balls just blatantly out and
I'm holding an industrial staple gun,
getting ready to staple my
ball sack to my leg. And I say,
this is not art.
This is just to be offensive
as stable. My boss to my
leg. And so like, you know,
being that it was Louisiana
in one of these parishes,
they deemed that felony obscenity,
which was the saving grace man.
Because like,
because of the story on that one was like
Steve O got arrested for stapling his
balls to his leg.
You know,
like the thing with the kid didn't really
play that much in the media. You know,
he did. He did sue me.
Yeah. For like brain damage.
I don't think even he had brain damage,
but I'll tell you right now,
he had Brendan for 100%. You get
spiked on your head and some cells die.
I mean, maybe 100%
right. But yeah, I like,
uh, I got, I got properly
sued. So did you go to cu?
Did you lose or did you go to
court? I mean, it was dead settled.
We settled it and see
how much he got 50 grand.
That's as if it's not that good.
But you know,
I think that that's what it
was. It wasn't, did you talk
to them? Maybe 50 grand?
Was my legal fees.
I can't remember.
Bounces. You go, why'd you spike them
on his head? Why didn't just grab him?
Like can just grabbed him. I know grabbing
him would have been funny, you know,
just grab and take them out of their help.
You know the whole
throw him into the audience. Second stage
divers. Yeah. Yeah. They really, really,
it was upsetting.
They shouldn't have done that.
See the problem is you give people
a green light like that, right?
You've seen some shit the
bouncers have done to people.
When people climb onto that stage,
there's a green light. I mean it's like,
it's sort of like the cop thing,
you know like when,
when cops like did you see that video?
Recent video of the cop grabbing
the school girl. She's in her desk.
She won't get out of her desk and he
just fucking rag dolls her and slams her
and the desk on the ground.
It's when cops have the green light.
When they can do whatever they want to do,
then you're leaving it up to the
discretion of this guy that's probably not
thinking that straight.
A little stressed out.
Yeah. I got beat up by a few
bounce. There's one guy grabbed me,
took me out back and just
like push me against the wall.
Just kept on slapping him in
the face and wouldn't let me go.
And he like sat there for like 10.
I was like 18 and he's just like
wailing on my face. Then you'll be like,
you going to do that to give
him motherfucker and then
just like punch me again.
I felt like I was captured.
Like if I was kidnapped. Yeah.
That's kind of grabbing the salt really.
Like, cause I was outside of the club.
He was just ramming the,
against the wall and shit.
Like they're not supposed to do that yet,
but we left that club
in Louisiana that night.
I knew I was going to hear about
it again. And um, and Sharon off,
like it took a couple of
weeks, but um, you know,
I was like sleeping off a cocaine bender
and, and uh, my roommate comes out,
he says, hey man, you really got to get
up for this. And there's like the La,
the La fugitive division. They
had it like they, they had, uh,
a fugitive warrant out of
Louisiana. The with um, for you.
Yay. Yeah, there's a, the,
there are two, two charges,
the felony obscenity and then the, the
second, second degree battery thing. La,
she just let that felony obscenity slide,
but they should be like,
you keep that yourself,
you fucking redneck douchebags yeah,
but you know that I love that charge.
And the thing is my favorite Jack.
Right.
But the thing was that like they,
they,
they gave me a $120,000 bail,
like, or warrant for,
uh, for the, the battery.
And then for the felony obscenity
they gave me a million. Oh my God.
The size showed up on the, the
like the fugitive list, like,
and like pull position number one
with one point $12 million bail.
Oh my God said they arrested position.
And uh, and so like they,
they, they brought me in and
they're like, what'd you do?
And I'm like, I stapled my
boss to my leg, you know,
like that nobody can understand it.
And I,
and I was in La County jail
and the protective custody
of where I'll be starting
on December 9th, you're going to put
you in protective custody. White. Yeah.
I mean like I'm,
I'm like,
I kind of high dude any you would
be in protective custody to and uh,
you know that, I mean, I, at the time
it was 2002 I just got my back Tattoo,
but the movie wasn't out yet. It's
nobody knew about it. And the cops like,
we're pretty psyched to have me in there.
And they,
they brought me into their office,
whatever,
like they're giving me like boxes and
boxes of cookies and stuff and pictures of
my bad tattoo. I remember there they were
like, oh dude, you'll be fine in here,
man. Were taking a picture
then my self portrait. Oh yeah,
that's right.
And they were like,
oh, you'll be fine in here,
man. This is Robert Downey
jr block. You know, like, uh,
we've had the, their listing off
all the celebrities that, that,
that have been in there. Yeah. Tommy
Lee, like everybody near there like,
and an odbs always in here.
You're actually in his cell.
Yeah. Fuck yeah, this was a good one. Um,
the longest I was in jail
was 10 days in Orlando for,
uh, that was, that was for drunk driving.
Now that's fucked up. Yeah. Like that,
that was fucked up. And I remember
like, that was in 1996. And, um,
I mean, I hadn't really broken
out yet, you know, so, uh,
like I, I couldn't really afford,
I mean, I barely could afford, um,
to get to Orlando. Like I lived in south
Florida, like near West Palm Beach.
And so I could, I just scraped
money together for a, uh,
for a greyhound bus to get to Orlando.
And I was like,
I can't afford, I can afford to
get there once for my arraignment.
I can't afford to like go over,
get rained and then set a date and then
come back and then come back again.
And My, my, uh, I had a public defender,
the public defender had said, yeah,
I saw the video. We're not going to be
able to do much about this. You know,
that was the one where my
arrest report said, uh,
defendant declined roadside sobriety tests
stating he would prefer to take a nap
because I was trying, I was trying to
argue that I wasn't actually drunk.
I was just really tired
and uh,
so sides have told the public, the
public defender Guy was like, man,
I can't afford to like go home and come
back again. So they got the arraignment.
Can we just like plead guilty and like
asked that I go to jail like right away
I said that. So, so that's,
that's what we did and I actually did
the whole 10 days. So what is, uh,
what's worse? Mexico.
Orlando, as far as jail, um,
well that the Mexico
was just like holding,
you know,
like Orlando was like proper,
like proper Jelic like process and it
was pretty mellow because like in Orlando
they said like, uh, you know,
as you get like, you know,
process, you know, you could,
you get, you get like
orientation, you know,
kind of breakdown of what it's going to
be like. They give you a tub of like a,
like a Tupperware tub of
like your belongings where
you've got like, whatever,
like your blanket. Like
it's so like, you know,
they won't let you have a razor but like
a toothbrush and they're like, this year,
this is your, your belongings. Okay.
Like if you're going to have
it at the foot of your bed,
you're going to keep
it like this and like,
fucking don't Piss us off.
Don't do anything wrong.
Because if you here pack up
your belongings, you know,
then what that means is a,
then you're going to pack all your shit
into your tub and you're going into the
fucking dungeon, you know?
And what that means, like, uh,
is that like if you're in the dungeon
than down there, they're like,
and they're just not, there's a,
you're just not on camera down there.
Like anything can happen to you.
Like, and, and like a, you know,
that was like sort of the, the incentive
to like be on your best behavior,
you know, because up here
like everything's on camera
like you can, you know,
and it was just like you don't want to,
you don't want to go to the,
they're just letting you know that
if you, if you fuck, if you fuck up,
if you fuck up,
you're going down and bad shit's going to
happen to you cause you're going to be,
because the only people go
down to the dungeon are like,
like dangerous people that you don't
want to be like fucking with, you know,
like they're going to be with
you. And that's that. Yay.
I basically like basically like the,
the,
the worst people who are more inclined
to hurt you are in the dungeon and yeah,
they,
if I remember,
cause I remember like being like always
on camera no matter what happened.
I don't know if it was no cameras,
but they're just like,
we're not going to like
down there and nothing can,
nothing's going to be nothing.
Nothing gets stopped. Like
you're going to get far,
you're going to get, I'm going
to be fucked. And then it worked.
It kept like everything pretty like civil,
you know, like, cause I, I was, I was,
you know, very well behaved. No.
When you're in jail for 10 days,
in 10 days,
can you get drugs and 10 days or do you
have to like get to know the system?
I don't, I don't think that you're going
to have as much luck in county jelly.
Like county jail by definition means
that you have a sentence of less than one
year and then at the point of a, of it
being one year, then it's called prison.
And in prison I think it's like,
that's where you can get whatever
you want and all that. Like, yeah,
I don't think La,
I don't think like jail is,
is as you know, probably make hooch is
probably the big thing. Right. I mean,
and maybe like, like I even, I don't have
that much experience so I don't know.
But like I couldn't get, uh, yeah,
I was doing like back flips for
extra food and Shit, you know,
let me know and we'll give you food. Like
the people that worked there, like God,
other inmates, I that like the
people that worked there, you know,
when they had the cart that came
by. And um, and I remember too,
like there was like a, in, in Orlando,
the jails are big business and Orlanda
because it's kind of like Mecca, you know,
like maybe even more than Mecca.
Like more families like travel
from all over the world too.
It's like the biggest sec tourist thing.
So like the business is like,
they say like,
you come to Orlando on vacation,
you leave on probation
and he return on violation
and a,
the theme parks, they're
right. They have Disneyland,
they fucking seaworld Orlando and San
Antonio closing seaworld down because in
the, in California they just
made it illegal for them to read.
Dude, they fucking made the, the,
the band captive breeding in California,
banned captain breeding,
which means that it only applies to the
San Diego seaworld. But that fucking, uh,
came down,
whatever that decision was,
it was made official like within two
days of me getting my jail sentence.
That's amazing. And I like to think,
Matt, maybe it's such a coincidence,
but I like to think that I got, people
started talking about it, you know,
like thinking about it and then they're
like, you know what? Fuck those people.
Well you definitely did.
He definitely put some attention on it,
but there's been some attention
on it for quite a while.
And the movie black fish was the big wars.
That was the big one that woke up.
A lot of people when they just
realize like, Whoa, what, what, what,
what is this place killed?
See Road for me forever.
I used to love it going as a kid, I
was always telling you like, you're,
you're going to watch prisoners,
you're going to watch slaves.
And it's Super Fun to Dan. It's super
fucked there. They're like water people.
I mean there really are like as smart
as human beings just don't affect her
environment harder too because like just
their, their loyalty and shit like that.
Like, humans aren't that loyal?
Well, you could say that,
but some humans are and dolphins killed
a lot of babies. Right. You know,
like there, there's, they kill baby
dolphins. They rape a lot. This,
they're not the best. Right. I mean
there's not way. So even killing whales,
killer whales killed dolphins. Oh
yeah. And whales. The whales alive.
Like this is a hard fucking
world. And the ocean, the word,
the ocean's a doggy dog world or a
dolphin eat baby world or a whale killer.
Whale whale.
Sure.
There has never been an instance of
a killer whale, you know, and people,
I wouldn't like to calm orchids. That org
is never a tag to Cayman and the wild.
It's true. When we were filming wild boys,
we went to Alaska and we will be like,
ran across a pod of, uh, uh, of,
of orcas and um, we had Manny,
the crazy shark guy, you know,
like Tarzan looking dude, the ride
sharks everywhere and he was so jazzed.
He sees his killing these fucking
killer whales in the wild. He's like,
like just dives in to go swim with
them, you know, and like, uh, and we,
we had power, we had an inflatable
killer whale there too. And like we,
we towed Pontius like on it,
you know,
like try to like vape,
but you can,
you swim towards these orchids and
then they're out man. They want,
they're not to want to hang with you.
Yeah, the, but they have saved people.
They've saved drowning people. Oh yeah.
People would capsize
boats. They've actually looked,
lifted them up and help them be there.
They're very smart.
They say that they have dialects,
they have like you can tell they're
different accents. They, they,
they recognize each other.
They stay with the same family for life.
That's why it's so fucked
up when they take them away.
Like you're stealing someone away
like a child away from their mother.
It's so fucking dark. And when you see
those seaworld commercials, they're like,
we haven't taken orchids from
the wild and over 34 years.
That's, you imagine if there was a
commercial for like Nabisco and the Bisco.
It was like,
we haven't stolen slaves in over 34 years.
The slides that we have,
we have had them for a long time.
That's basically what they're
saying and that's it's fun.
Dab Dude, go ahead. I grew up with a zero
day in Ohio and it's really weird how,
you know, growing up they
don't teach you that like, hey,
we captured these guys and that you
always kind of thought like, oh,
they're injured and we helped
them and that's why they're here.
It was always kind of like, oh,
I like c row because I like,
I want to see these dolphins do good
and be better. But you know, after,
after watching that movie you realize,
you know, it's exact opposite.
They just kind of kidnapped slavery.
Yeah.
They say a dolphin has a cerebral cortex.
It's 40% larger than a human beings.
I believe it. Yeah, they don't,
they don't have the ability
to alter their environment.
They can't pick things up and move
them around. They can't send emails,
but they don't have to.
They live in a three d world.
Like they can fly around and their world,
I mean they come up for air,
but in their world they can go left
right up, down. They don't need fingers.
Like it's not necessary. So our
idea, like what's intelligence?
It's like if you can't type something,
if you can't build a house,
you're a fucking idiot. You
know? That's how we look at it.
But those things that we
define as intelligent when
it comes to human beings are
completely unnecessary. They go where
the water's warm. The Fisher everywhere.
Fisher stupid as fuck. They swim
up to him. My Jack, him dolphins,
probably never starved to death. I
mean, they're faster than fish. I mean,
I guess they die of old age,
but you gotta think like if,
unless they run out of fish, fish are
probably easiest fuck for them to catch.
They just swim up and Jack Them.
It's like food is floating around the sky.
Imagine if every way you went,
like their sandwiches just floating
around in front of you and just hang out
with your homeys and grab a sandwich. I
mean, that's definitely worth shit. Yeah,
that's dolphin world.
But they do do some dark shit,
but they usually do it in the name of
breeding. It's why female dolphins,
so like super slutty through super
slutty because they want to have,
because the mail, they can't
recognize lines of paternity so they,
they don't necessarily know
whether or not the babies, there's,
so if they've go up to a chick and she's
got babies and they have never had sex
with her,
the women,
the female dolphins won't have sex until
their baby has reached like maturity
until they're baby can swim away.
It's like a few years I believe.
So when the males come to females
and they have babies and they haven't
had sex with a male with the female,
they'll sometimes kill the babies so
that she'll have sex with them again.
It's pretty fucked up lines. Just Shit
like that to bears do shit like that too.
Yeah. That's the other thing. That
video with you in the line line.
What's that?
A few times on this show and freaked,
but any case I'm going to jail
for fucking good cause man,
I used to get arrested for
fucked up shit man. You know,
like drugs and violence and Canada.
I got arrested for violence. What kind
of, yeah, we should do. There was,
it was a salt, like, um, the, and, and
we actually ran away from cops and,
and God away. It was on
New Year's Eve when, uh,
2003, I want to say it was a, uh,
it was 2003 and turning into 2004 did
this big show and some fucking asshole got
on stage and like snuck up like whatever.
And like sucker punched me
while I was on stage, you know,
like a fucking punching in.
And so of course everybody grabs him and
starts beating the shit out of him and,
and uh, and I'm like,
and I'm like, you know,
on the microphone saying fucking kick
his ass, you know, like, you know,
trying to like tell him it
started as an assault on me,
but by the time I was like,
Nah, I'll kick his ass.
And they're beating them
just all blood, like, uh,
and pressing Lacey,
the big guy on jackass had his microphone.
He was just like grading
the dude's forehead off,
like so it was kind of bloody live from
that. And then they like, they carry them,
uh,
you know,
the cat and then they're carrying them
away and I'm like hauled off and kicked
the guy, you know? And so like
you got in trouble for that.
And I did gather that the cops
were called and, um, we just,
I think maybe like ran off the stage
and she's dipped, you know, like,
and got away. But then I
was back, um, you know, I'm,
you know,
my new tour in a fucking I was
in is in Calgary and I'm on the,
on the, I'm on the, uh, the morning
news promoting my shows and they said,
have you ever been to Calgary before?
I said, oh, yeah, like I, I was,
I was here and we really beat
the crap out of this guy.
And then we ran from cops and got away.
So like you in Canada?
I'm Canadian.
I have a Canadian passport and I'm also
American and I'm also British, but, uh, I,
and my mom was born in Canada. My Dad was
born in America, I was born in England,
so I'm all three.
Well you saw all you have to do is be
born in a country like that and you get
her citizen citizen,
then they'll allow you to be a citizen of
America to correct. Yeah. You can't be,
you can't be, it can't be a
resident of more than one place.
It can be a citizen and all I got,
I didn't marry like a Australian chicken
stone in New Zealand would be even
better.
[inaudible] quadro right.
I'm triple national. The thing was though,
like I'm some bragging about like, yeah,
would beat up this guy and
fucking ran from the cops.
And then when I left that
trip hand over the passport,
like a to the immigration
guy, like you know, going
through the airport, he's like,
yeah,
go ahead and wait in this room
and send the yeah,
send the cops came and
arrested me and I was in,
I mean they held me for like 12
hours or 10 hours or something.
And what they say when they arrested you,
they said there's where you
have an outstanding warrant,
which I think is pretty funny.
It's like an outstanding warrant.
Right.
Why did you let you go after 12 hours?
Because I paid bail like a $10,000 bail.
You have to go back and go to court. I
mean, it was a misdemeanor, you know,
whatever. Like I got it
sorted out from, um, you know,
like whatever Canada's and play. When it
comes to salt though, like if you can't,
it isn't play when it comes
to anything man. Like I,
Canada is the fucking toughest
country to get into. I mean,
like everybody gets held up if you've
got a drunk driving arrest and you're not
allowed in. I saw it. I don't, I don't
know if there was that big of a deal,
but, uh, but whatever, you know, it was
great because I was able to sort of,
you know,
like clear away the wreckage of my past,
like for all the fucked up Shit I've
done. Like, I like to think I've made it.
All right. You know, how about the dude
that got spiked on his fucking head?
He's fine.
It's like a grand man
special k through that 50
grand the first day. That's a,
it's, it's a weird thing like
the Canadian thing, like, um,
they live right next door to us,
so they gotta to be real careful about
like fugitives sneaking across the border.
So they're super strict about any
weirdness. Like Eddie Bravo, well,
a long time ago got pulled over,
not even arrested for having illegal,
he,
he used to work for check cashing company,
so he used to take these bags of cash
around with them and he had a concealed
weapons permit.
And so he gets pulled over by the
cops and he tells the cops a officer,
I work for check cashing company, I have
a large sum of cash and I also have a, a,
a concealed weapon. And, uh, here's,
here's my permits here, my paperwork.
And so they take them out of the car
that handcuff him, check his paperwork,
they got everything seems in order,
you're free to go. And they let them go.
So every time he goes to Canada,
they bring up that every
time still on his record.
And his record still on his record
in wasn't even an arrest. He pulled,
they pulled him over, they check
me. But when involves a gun,
if it involves anything where
you like just man's cash,
everybody's pretty uptight about.
But it was, it was all legit. It was,
he worked for check cashing company.
So he had a total 100% iron clad excuse.
They let him out.
I mean he never brought him to jail.
They let him go. Yeah. But still,
every time he goes to
Canada they check him.
And James had a real hard time cause
Kevin James got in a street fight like in
like high school or college or
something like that and got arrested.
No conviction, no nothing. But every time
that he would go to Canada, like when,
before he was famous, we do the
Montreal comedy festival together.
Every time we'd go to Canada,
they would fuck with them. They, Australia
is the same way, man. Australia is, um,
like maybe even harder to
get into then Canada. And,
and I'm not Australian, so
when I, when I go to Australia,
I have to, um, like fulfill.
Like with my visa application,
I have to submit my
entire criminal record,
like my whole history and it's like so
long. It's hilarious. Like, uh, yeah,
I mean there's even a bunch of stuff
I didn't even mention like, you know,
like to be getting arrested
all over the states and stuff,
but nothing was really how many times
you've been arrested. Uh, there's one in,
uh, in Philadelphia, like
public urination was like,
when you kind of mellow, it was more
like funny than anything. Um, and uh,
there's my first drunk driving.
She have like,
those look forward for five.
Right,
right, right. Counting
off the days in prison.
Like I last year that like,
you know,
they're like a year and
a half ago or something.
I did a whole Australia tour
and um, you know, I was,
I was like putting it all together
and I made like a youtube video, like,
like actually going through my whole
like official thing and like with all the
paperwork, you know, my criminal
criminal past or whatever.
And at the same time too, um, the, uh, um,
the Australian tour promoter wanted,
um,
need to have a name for my tour, you know,
like, oh, we'd like to have, you know,
a name for the tour. And so I'm going
through my whole arrest history.
And so I told him,
yeah man,
it's Steevo guilty as charged cause they
ended the name of my tour, you know.
And so that's been the name of my tour
for like a year and a half, you know,
like if anybody wants to know the name
of it, that's what it is every time.
And now I'm so excited to be
here today is because, uh,
in like less than three weeks in Austin,
Texas,
I'm taping my first comedy
special for showtime.
And it's of course called
Steevo guilty as charged.
Were you taping it at the paramount
theater in Austin, Texas? I've been there.
I did it. So it's so fucking,
I mean, I just love Texas.
I love Texas so much and it's the one
place that I haven't been to with the,
with the, with this tourist. So it's
like, oh, you have a fresh, fresh crowd,
you know, and um, we don't doing on tour.
You doing street stand up with it.
It's,
it's like a one man show where
like, uh, it's totally standup.
It's totally stories and like on
story points throughout the show,
like I do like super fucked up
stones, you know, like what, like,
uh,
I mean when,
when I come in like I'm
gonna like blast fucking, uh,
like a 12 pack of soda cans on my head,
you know,
like until they're all like
busted it open. What? Yeah.
You just take the candidate,
it's not open and you just fucking
keep smashing it in your head. So,
and it's sort, it's going to be showed
up with all the lights, you know,
like all the lights and then
when, once it was, once it breaks,
it's like spraying like super fucking
a lot, you know? And so it looked out,
man, I'll break like at least six. Um,
and uh, and then, um, whenever like,
you know, don't look so healthy
for someone who's done so much,
I can walk normal. Yeah. You seem
to be your voice. A little raspy,
but everything's coming out good.
I appreciate it dude.
But yeah, then like whatever,
at the top of my show I like,
I got some crowd work and stuff like,
um,
and I don't even waste any time before I
started fucking bagging on Carlos, man.
See Ya, your crowd work well. Yeah,
because like all I pulled out,
like I'm, one of my other
big bits is like, you know,
like I'll pull the crowd about,
um, you know, ladies clap.
If you've ever received a dick
pic from someone, you know,
and it's like really like, it's
like one of my like, you know,
best like a Crowdwork
bits and, um, you know,
after I get done like with all like
the back and forth with, you know,
it's just really fucking funny
and to pull like, you know,
now like what kind of Dick Pics did you
get from guys that you weren't hooking
up with?
You know,
like now clap if you've got a dick pic
from a guy that you were not hooking up
with it all and like, look less, but
still a ton. That chick's clubbing came.
Now I get a clap really loud if you
went on to have sex with that guy,
it's just crickets, you know? I
like, so it doesn't work, you know?
And then I have to, I'd
tell him like, you know,
and I just saw this thing recently and
so I just started doing it like, um,
uh, say, uh, you know, I saw
this funny thing I about Dick
Pics and it was so funny.
I stole it, you know, it was one of
these memes where a girl is saying,
receiving a dick pic from a guy who's
just like her cat bringing her a dead
mouse says she says,
I can see that you are very proud
but I'm not touching it.
Right. And like lyric,
that's fucking fun. And people will
like actually clap, you know? And I say,
and I still like every time I'm like, oh
my God, I can't fucking like this floors.
Me Getting applause for a
joke I told you I stole.
I said Fuck,
I love this so much.
I decided I'm going to do a whole
fucking bit just out of jokes. I stole,
I call it the Carlos men see a bit so
that I just say really quick because I
don't like to fucking, I don't even,
I'm not even comfortable doing this,
but I'm like, I'll tell you two jokes
when you've heard of when you haven't,
but I've stolen both
here with Greg. He's doing,
I don't want to ruin it.
I want people to come to Austin so much.
Cause like normally I do comedy clubs,
you know, and I saw the lines share my
tickets, like once I get there, you know,
I don't do a lot of advanced ticket sales.
I show up and I get on the radio
and people are like, oh, he's here.
And then I do great. You know,
I like, I do really well,
but in this case for, and it's
November 21st this month, um,
at the paramount theater in Austin.
Like I don't have the luxury of waiting
to get there to fucking sell tickets
because it's a fucking showtime
comedy special. You know,
we have to have that place sold
the fuck out. What's the date?
November 21st and it will tweet the shit
out of it. Oh dear. I'm so stoked man.
Thank you. Yeah. November 21st paramount
theater. You can like, find it at Steve O.
Dot Com. We'll tweet it will tweet it
will tweet it after the show's over. Yeah.
She brand,
I know like a million people that are
listening in the youtube notes that he'd
be there. Okay. We'll put it in the
UK. Appreciate it. Um, yeah. And,
uh, what is it? Well,
it's going to be a bunch of people wanting
to see you smash soda cans. Oh Dude,
he bet it. I used to do it. I used
to do it like on and comedy clubs,
like six times a week I would break
like, you know, like, like one,
two or three and a fucking wake up in the
morning and I'd fucking like get a guy
to bed and I'm walking like
fucking diagonally. I'm like, look,
my whole fucking equilibrium was off.
And I was like,
I've got to stop hitting
myself in the fucking head,
but yet you're going to do it
again. I'm going to do it. But yeah,
that's the only two shows
I was doing it like all the time you
doing it like Wednesday, Thursday,
I'm doing it. I'm doing it. Right, right,
right, right. Exactly. By the time Sunday.
Fucking totally. But yes. So any case,
I'll be smashing the cans. I do like
that, you know, got like a couple of bits,
like with the crowd work and
then the fucking, you know,
by the time I'll even tell you the judge
said, I'm fucking thing. They're funny.
They're the ones I stall for the
Carlos men see it. But if you do that,
then the people, you're right,
you're right, you're right.
Thank you Joe. They listen, they
remember, they write shit down. Right.
Thank you Joe. But, um, but then like,
you know, after, after that, okay,
now I'm gonna really get into it. And
so it's sort of like a, I started off,
uh, you know, addressing like how
people have asked me for so long. Like,
how did I get into it? How to Jack has,
she had start and, uh, you know, I,
I give like a super condensed,
like super hilarious, uh,
like sort of fucking genesis
story. Like, you know,
starting with like me and high school
and getting caught dealing drugs and you
know, like, and, uh, you know,
legs going to college and just
fucking up royally. I mean,
I've fucked up royally it in college
and a college. It was so bad.
Well, within two weeks of class,
starting my freshman year, I was,
I was on final disciplinary probation,
which is fucking impressed.
Two weeks I got my room rated
like, uh, you know, they,
they've found alcohol and weed
and shit and said like, you know,
so they relocated me into another
fucking dorm, you know, and they're like,
you are on final disciplinary probation.
And like I climbed up like that broke
out a window and climbed onto the roof.
You know,
there's a radio tower on top of the
roof and I climbed up that and someone
spotted me from the ground and,
and said the cops came on the roof and
they kicked me out of the dorms and I was
failing the fuck out of my classes.
And then I just got in a van with this
dude and just took off without him
withdrawing. So, so,
so I got a in a van with
this deal never ends.
Well I got,
I failed out,
I got kicked out and I dropped out.
Oh my gosh. I call it overachieving.
Fucked up that at all. I know. And like,
that's the thing, it's like, you know,
people were like, when I was leaving
the University of Miami, it's like,
well what are you going to do now?
And I'm like,
I'm going to fucking video tape
fucked up shit. And I'm going to,
I'm going to be [inaudible] 93 so
you had this idea in 93 Oh yeah,
I was. And even then I was like, man,
like I had like special fucking skills,
you know,
like I had like,
I was really fucking good
at drinking bong water,
didn't care, I'm working. It was
very much people, louvers said, I
don't even care how murky it was
a whole life never comes out of
your mouth. I live a good life. And,
and like I was like, you know, it
was Miami, so I was like super,
like I would like blow off class and
I'd be like practicing jumping on the
diving boards at the, at the pool. And
I'm like, I'm never going to be a diver.
But if I had jumped strictly off of like
roofs of like apartment buildings and
shit into shallow pools, then
it's bad at. So I was like,
I got pretty good at that.
Oh my God.
Like my specialty was like setting
myself on fire with like hairspray and
rubbing alcohol.
And so at the point where I'm not even
like fucking five minutes into the show
at this point and I had to say my
specialty was setting myself on fire with
hairspray and rubbing alcohol.
So I'm going to at that point
demonstrate like it's gamma.
Do you like that in the
theater they let you go to,
I used to do in comedy clubs all the time
but I kept getting so hurt like I just
fucking,
you know like,
like cause cause what I do is like I
may do like kind of a deluxe version for
this one. Like I'm going to start
with like a can of hairspray.
I'm going to like spray and my like all
the hair on my head like heavily with
the hairspray.
I'm going to climb on top of a,
of a table on the stage and Dallas,
my arm with rubbing alcohol,
fill my mouth with lamp oil
and then we're going to bottle
flute. Never seen, not that. Then
I'm going to click on a click,
a lighter and light my arm on fire.
Like just the rubbing alcohol and
my skin all the way up to your hair.
Well like a drop will like from when I
pour it like on the table there'll be a
puddle and so like a drop,
we'll stay on fire probably and then
it's to the table will be on fire.
My arm's on fire and then like,
so I'm going to my arms,
a torch when I do a front flip standing
on top of the table and simultaneously
as I do the front flip blow of fireball,
like off of my arm,
like which is a huge with lamp lamp oil.
It goes crazy.
So like the lamp oil and as I'm flipping
from like the front flip my head,
like everything just goes
right through the fire.
So when I crash on the table on my bag,
now my head's on fire.
And so then I get get up
and like kind of like,
like flail around the stage with my head
on fire and my buddy comes riding out
with a mouthful of lamp oil and he comes
running up to me and he uses my head as
a torch and just,
you know,
it blows a fucking huge
fireball off of my head. And uh,
and then like we'll figure out
how to put me out, you know,
then we'll figure it out.
Right, right. And He,
maybe he'll have like a towel or
something because I've gotten like a towel
fire me. No, I mean I
wouldn't do that. I'll go on,
like my goal will be to
disease my bare hands,
but does the thing is like
I've done it where I'd hold it,
you're going to do this?
Oh No. Oh fuck dude.
[inaudible]
yeah.
Oh my God, I didn't think about it cause
I remember like, wouldn't think about it.
Well, I mean it's just theater.
Like, I thought I didn't,
it didn't occur to me that they would
find out that I was going to do it until I
already did it. A million plus
people are going to hear this.
Someone's going to tell
him, well, all right,
well then fucking I better figure it out.
I'll come agent guarantee how fire Katia,
I've done,
I've done it in the fucking thousand
places I've ever let anybody know
beforehand on a podcast.
I feel like a fucking
flashback from Calgary coming.
It's like all the times you've hit
yourself in the head with sodas you've
knocked out.
They used to be planning
segment of your brain that's just
shorted out like a bad fuse lodge.
You won't figure it out. I got maybe
we'll have like a bunch of people with,
with a fire extinguisher.
Definitely have a bunch of people let
the lens of Fucking Fire Marshal No.
Or whatever. Do a bed like this is
so important, man. I have to do it.
Aren't you scared that like maybe you
get really injured and you can't finish?
I mean like one time I like
burned my neck really bad and um,
it hurts, but it's not going
to like stop me, you know? Wow.
Like half the rest of your show
could be you looking, you know,
like steam coming off
your face first time.
That'll be a real problem.
It's like this part of the
fun all fucked up. Yeah.
I mean I think it's whatever. I mean the,
the, the crazier, the better, you know,
like, uh, I'm, I'm,
I'm in this fucking really make
an impression it's going to,
it's going to go on and there's
just gonna be like, it's sort of,
it's kind of a one man show.
But the thing is like, I, it's,
it's also like fully stand up, man.
I've been on tour doing standup
for five years now. Yeah. I remember when
you first started doing it. I was like,
that's it.
Cause you,
you first started doing it like right
around the time when you're getting sober.
Right.
I had been sober for like two years
when I really dove into it and that was,
I wasn't sober yet when I first
started. Oh, you weren't? Yeah,
first time I tried it was 2006. Oh, okay.
So you took a break and then came back.
Just dabbled in it heavy until I'd
been sober for a couple of years.
But that's pretty much what you do now.
Pretty much. Yeah. Now as being sober,
does that fuck with your ability
to do a lot of these crazy stunts?
Well, obviously not, you
know, I would say that, uh,
I mean if you're like sober,
like
deliberately hurting herself isn't
necessarily easier, but it's like,
I never did that because you
know, I, because I was wasted.
I did it because I'm an attention whore
and sober and not take away the drugs
and alcohol. I'm still an
attention whore, you know?
But you embrace the clock he had.
Why do you think I have a fucking
tattoo of myself on my back? You know,
like everybody's favorite
topic of conversation isn't
themselves. I'm just like,
I think that's hilarious and I'm
cool with admitting it, you know?
But it just seems like if you were fucked
up on drugs and you made this career
of like getting hammered and going out
and doing wild crazy stunts that got you
injured and then you cut out the
getting fucked up part. Right.
But you're still injuring yourself.
I mean,
injury. My Saab isn't as, as it isn't
like isn't as much of it, you know?
I mean, sure, I'll still do it. I don't
carry mine injured you've ever gotten.
I threw myself off a balcony
at the University of Miami
after I dropped out and
then I came back and just lived there
even though I wasn't allowed to. Uh,
and there's like a keg party and I was
trying to like impress this fat chick and
I was on the thousand,
but I had taken too many pills and drank
too much booze and I'm telling them,
this girl, this was in,
uh, I think it was January,
January of 1995 and I'm telling this girl,
I said,
I'm going to be like a fucking Super Rad
stunt man and we're on the second floor
balcony. I tell her like,
you know, like, okay,
like I'm going to be like this fucking
gnarly stunt man. Like picture this,
like imagine like, like there's a
fight on the balcony. You right.
And like I get punched and I'm like
pretending I get punched and I just throw
myself off the balcony. Now.
I used to throw myself off
of balconies all the time,
but not when I was at fucked up and not
when I was trying to pretend that I had
been punched.
And so I'm like holding my whole game
plan where like the way I would do it,
I did did it different. I
didn't catch the bottom, uh,
with my hand and then let myself go.
I just spun over the railing and so I
spun over the railing and Linda let me
fucking face on the bottom of, and
I broke, I broke, I have a cat,
scans are so gnarly.
Like I broke my cheekbone,
a broke 17th,
I had 10 stitches in my chin,
a concussion and a broken wrist.
And that's actually pretty
good considering you fell
onto what concrete and I
was landing that landed there. And I was
fucking face down from where I'm from,
where I needed the 10 stitches. I had
like a, a pool of blood, like growing.
I was face down and I'm not even
fucking twitch and a finger at all.
I'm going to just like, there's
just blood pooling, you know, and,
and I'm not moving and everyone's like,
thinks I'm probably dead.
But my buddies were like, they're
like, man, if he's not dead,
he's going to need that weed in his
pockets. I had like, I had like, kind,
we'd, you know, like,
like fucking proper good
weed in one pocket and like
swag weed and the other and,
and they, uh, you know, I'd pull
it out, pull it out and, and um,
and in the morning I knew my mom was like,
I didn't remember even remember landing,
like, I don't remember anything, you know,
and they called the ambulance,
whatever. And it came and, um,
and then in the morning,
like I woke up and I was so fucked up.
It was unbelievable.
But I knew my mom was on a cruise
ship in the Caribbean but I,
but I told them, I said, oh, I need to
call my mom. And they said, of course.
But what I did was I called my buddies
down at the University of Miami. I said,
hey,
I'm going to fucking leave out the
fucking emergency room entrance right now.
Come scoop me up and said I
broke out of the hospital in my,
in my gown and they came and picked me
up and I went back to the spot and I
stood like right over like the pool of
blood and had tried to pound a beer but I
couldn't because it hurts you that
and I couldn't eat or anything.
And I was like,
like my sinuses would like fill with
blood and then I would like hockey and you
know like you hock a Lougie
and Acog and then spit it out.
And it was just blood
Louise for like two weeks.
I tried to eat apple sauce and I couldn't
even fucking eat apple applesauce
cause I was so busted up.
And so the apple sauce,
a bowl of applesauce sat next to
my bed is with blood, Louise in it.
I just used it as a spitter.
Yeah. And I had like,
I had a,
I broke my wrist too.
And so I had the cast on my wrist for like
whatever you have it on for six weeks.
And my mom likes sort of
felt bad for me because my,
my broke 70th and so my fucking,
all my front teeth are all busted out
and she knew I was a fuck up, you know,
which teeth like got it
was, it was uh, like my,
my front one of my front ones and then
there was one that didn't break in.
The one on the other side of that one did
break. So it looked extra bad, you know,
like right. And, um, and, and my mom like
felt bad for me. She likes sorta had like,
you know, she felt bad for me and you
know, she's conserving enabler too.
So she said a dentist appointment for
me to get my teeth fixed, you know,
like, and she's going to pay for it. And
I'd still got the cast on my wrist and,
and the night before the fucking dentist
appointment or I'm going to get my
teeth fixed is when I get fucking
arrested for my first drunk driving,
you know,
and like,
and so they fucking take me into a Miami
Dade fucking county jail and I'm in the
holding cell there and one of the
fucking like correctional officers in the
jail,
it's in my fucking cast and says
that cast is a potential weapon,
you know, like, cause they like, uh, like
if I get into a fight in the holding cell,
now I'm going to have an unfair advantage
because I've got this cast on my arm.
So they're like, hey, you can't
be in this fucking holding cell.
You have to go in to this gnarly
fucking like a crazy fucking,
you know,
and so with like all the people are in
here for the longest stretch of time.
Oh God. You know. And they said,
the first thing I had to do was
go and take a photo, get naked,
and take a fucking shower in the back of
this big sell with all these bunk beds
and all these fucking creepy households.
And, uh, I'm like, this sucks man.
I called my mom and I was
like, mom, you know, like, you
know, I'm in jail, you know,
and she's like, she's like, you've
what? You know, like she, she says, ah,
I'm not bailing you out unless you
go door to door straight to rehab.
And I'm like, okay. So I went
to rehab like in 1995. And,
and um, I remember these
fucking guys like, uh,
the one of the counselor says
like a, yeah, you know, like,
I'm 95% of all alcoholics.
I died drunk of causes related directly
to alcoholism. You know, like most people,
like, they don't get sober, you know,
like, and I'm sitting there thinking, man,
this guy's telling me, like, if I
had like really wanting to get sober,
I got a 5% chance. I'm
like, fuck that, you know?
So I stayed loaded. Like I just
resigned myself to being loaded forever.
And it wasn't until like 13 years later,
I've suddenly got,
so him seeing that sort of all to me
fucking wasted. But what it did really,
what it,
what it did was it just made me not like
a get sober until I was really ready.
You know? I think it was conveyed.
You really ready. Well, I mean fuck,
I got like Knoxville pulled
an intervention on me and
like, uh, that's when,
you know, you're fucked up.
But I knew how upset I was.
One of my oldest. Yeah. You know,
you've got a problem when that's
your interventionists, you know. Ah,
what was going on that he had to step in?
Well,
I had this like fucking massive
mass email thing and I was like,
broadcasting my downward spiral
and like fucking real time to like,
you know, 200 of the most like, you know,
influential fucking people in
the entertainment industry whose,
who had the misfortune of
giving me their info, you know,
and it was just like more fucked up and
it's kept getting worse and worse. And,
and um,
and I got arrested for like
a felony cocaine possession.
There was another one of my fucking
arrests. Felony cocaine possession.
You have, so there's no such thing
as misdemeanor cocaine possession.
I don't even like a little bit. You got a
little, yeah, that's a felony. Yeah. Um,
but, uh, I got evicted, I got,
you know, arrested and you know,
like this is when I had like my,
my neighbor in this apartment building
I lived in was always calling the cops
because I deserved it.
Like he was a lawyer and I'm like an
asphalt and I'm always making all this
noise to,
the cops are always coming.
But typically they would get
to my apartment and they'd
be stoked. It'd be like,
oh no, wait Steve, oh, cool man. Have
a good night. And so like they would,
so they would take off, you know, they
would play knights and they'll go, yeah,
but this guy's just fucking, his
life was, was misery because of me.
But the thing was that like, because
I was such a fucking, you know,
loaded ass hole, I'm Tom, I fucking
drugs and fucking being wasted.
I was just became particularly mad at
him for always calling the cops on me.
So like I'd like fucking
take like a baseball bat,
like powered his door or whatever. Like
fuck you call the cops, you know, like,
and uh, and I was like, I was
in pound. I was like, you know,
I was like pounding on the
wall that separated our
apartment's like all the time.
It's like, how do you like that
Fucker, you know, how do you like that?
And a pounded on the wall so hard that I
fucking actually pounded a hole through
the wall where I'm looking into his
apartment eight and got C's apartment.
You look inside. I punched, I
was looking into, well, I mean,
well,
the thing was that I pounded enough and
then I took a broomstick and fucking
just pounded and pounded and pounded
until I got through, you know, so now he,
he calls the cops and they
actually have to arrest me for, uh,
for, uh, for whatever fucking vandalism,
you know, like it was a misdemeanor,
but I've been, I've now vandalized his
property but pounding through the wall.
So they come to arrest me and this time
it doesn't matter if they're stoked or
whatever, like, you know, and,
and I'm so blown out on fucking ketamine
and I don't know what's going on.
And I got fucking bag of
cocaine in my pocket and like,
and I'm, and I open up the
door. Like, I bet I'm shirtless.
I have no shoes on and a bag of cocaine
in my pocket. And I'm out of my mind.
And they're like,
hey,
we're taking me into jail because we
have to arrest you for, for a vandalism.
And I'm like,
it's going to be cold.
And so I'd like as a courtesy,
like you can go in there and put on a
shirt and put on some shoes and I'm like
fuck shirt and fucks
her. She's, meanwhile,
that would have been like the
perfect opportunity for me to go in,
take the bag of cocaine out of
my pocket and I put on, you know,
like it was a perfect opportunity,
but I'm like, fuck that, you know,
so they take me to jail with no shirt,
no shoes and a fucking,
and I get reared. They'd go
into your property, you know,
then when they process you into jail and
so they pull out a bag of cocaine and
they, they, they rearrest me
at the jail. Oh my God, I'm in.
So I'm in there for like three days or
something and it's on the news and the
apartment buildings fucking over me.
Even though I rented for apartments
in the building. One was,
one was a skate park,
one,
one was a Skatepark, one was, it's
sort of like my,
my,
my body's like the one my one guy
edited my videos and stuff is kind of an
office.
Had this like assistant and check
it just such a fucking joke.
I mean her job was just to tell people
that she couldn't find me and [inaudible]
had constantly change my flights
because I would always miss my flights,
you know? Uh, she was
like travel agent at best,
but I buy had an apartment for her
and then I had my bachelor pad,
so it was four and still
the fucking apartments,
like get the fuck out when you,
when you're ready for apartments and they,
you still get evicted. Like that's
when you know you fucked up. Well,
it was supposed to when one of them was
a skate park. Right. I know, but it was,
it was like,
it was like neck.
Then the next to it on one side was a
fucking like Russian hooker operation.
So they weren't complaining,
you know,
that dude's coming into fuck these
hookers all day long. Where did you live?
I have specific right across the street.
[inaudible]
a long time ago, but it was right across
the street from rock and roll. Ralph's.
Oh, right in the midst. Yeah. I mean,
right on the part of Sunset Boulevard.
The lawyers live in there.
Yeah. Shady, I guess.
I don't know that I ever
actually met him and I prompt me,
I mean yelling like through the door and
I go, whatever, maybe like a sunburn.
I wouldn't have recognized if you feel
like you want to go back and apologize to
him. I tried, I tried. I actually
had his email and um, you know,
I, I reached out to him and
I said, hey, like, you know,
it would mean a lot to me if like
we could meet up and you know,
and he just declined. So I had to respect
that, you know? But yeah, that was,
you had climbed in an email, he
declined. He declined to, to meet me.
And so I just sort of like,
when you're in that situation,
you want to go through and make things
right. You had to respect that, you know,
you can't like be persistent. So that,
so to make it right to that guy, like,
you know, it's called a living
amends where it sort of,
I'm not going to do that to anybody else.
And this is a part of thing about rehab.
It's like they ain't give me yeah,
of course. You know, like, I mean it's
basically a thing about life, you know.
But um, but something that they asked
you to do, like when you're, you,
you're going to rehab,
what rides?
It would be considered step nine
of the 12 steps, you know, we,
we made direct amends wherever possible
except when to do so would injure them
or others. So yeah. So
that's part of the deal.
And now I get finally get out of jail
and I come back and there's a fucking
eviction notice on my,
on my door, you know,
like get the fuck out within three days.
Oh actually that there was that.
Yeah, I got an end. Like I
had all drugs in my apartment,
so like I get back and like
there's the eviction notice,
but like I just go straight
for like the vials of ketamine.
I had like two or three more vials academy
and I cooked them up in the microwave.
You know, I've, I went digging through,
Cook them up in the morning. How do you,
how do you handle ketamine? Well, you,
I mean it's best and I never disliked
injected shit. I just never got that far.
But, um, you just cook it in the microwave
and it evaporates like the maybe water,
I dunno. And then you're left
with like the, uh, the plate.
It's like crusted to the plate and then
he scraped it up with like a card and
then snorted. Snorting. No. How'd you,
how'd you get started on ketamine?
Because ketamine is like a cat.
I love that Shit, dude.
I love dude. Like, uh,
that was my favorite man.
First Time I tried it. I don't
think so. Neil Brennan a,
he's a cocreator of the Chappelle show.
Standup comic.
He's been taking ketamine treatments
for depression. Oh my God.
Yeah. It's one of the more
recent treatments for depression.
Why that they've been, well,
because it resets the way you,
any intense psychedelic experience and
ketamine, even though it's a tranquilizer,
is thought of as a pretty
insane associative,
it's basically a pharmacy to go PCP.
Really? That's how you look at it.
Yeah. It's a is what it is, man. Really.
But did you have like out
of body experiences or any
experiences where you felt
like you went it to another
dimension and trip but you know,
the k whole experience? Um, some of
the experiences I had with ketamine,
like a purse,
I got uh,
we depth reception like
way fucking just chill.
I was like some fear and loathing
shit, you know, like you're not like,
you know about it.
Like I've been,
I remember live like my fucking
feet are like 30 feet away.
That's fucked up. I remember one time I
was in a, in a, in a hotel room in London.
There's what like with,
with just way too much of the shit and
like at one point the whole hotel room
just started free falling. And I'm,
even when I'm in the sky, well nothing,
it was like, like looking
up. Like rather than like,
like I could actually see like,
uh,
like kind of an elevator shaft type deal
that it was falling through, you know,
like it was just the, the hotel room
started free falling. And I'm like,
just thinking, whoa. And I remember
being so stoked. I was thinking,
I remember thinking Jim Morrison
doesn't have shit on me.
Like I'm so good at being a drug
addict, you know, like a or whatever,
you know. But um, so yeah,
I've been cooking up the ketamine
and whatever and I pack is it come,
but it's in a liquid form because we
file file where you would stick a needle.
Let me shoot at a cat usually.
Sure.
Category for I think horse as much.
I mean,
PCP started out as an anesthetic,
that was the,
the idea for it. But yeah, within
like two hours of being, of,
of walking out of jail,
I have my buddy videotaping me,
I'm jumping up and down on
the roof of a parked car,
screaming God is the son,
whatever that means.
Like and like,
and like this.
And I got it figured out.
[inaudible] need the sun for and,
and, and like, this squad of like,
security guards like comes over and like,
you know, what's going on.
You know, like, I mean,
it's amazing that I didn't go right
back into jail for another pockets for
drugs, you know, and so then, but I'm to,
and I did that bender lasted for, I dunno,
like maybe 24 hours and now I'm,
I've got my three days is, is
like, I've got one more day,
I gotta be out of the apartment. So
I send the mass email list. I say,
hey, you know, like with
all the jackass guys on it,
but of course 200 high power people
in Hollywood need to know this,
that like, Hey Knoxville
and guys, you know, I've, I,
I gotta be out of my apartment tomorrow
and I'm not fucking leaving my apartment.
Um, I don't want to fucking leave here
until I jumped out of my bedroom window.
You know,
it,
she'll be like a 25 foot drop onto the
sidewalk and I need you guys to bring
something for me to land on.
Preferably a hot tub or like put a hot
tub and cannon ball into it out of my
bedroom window. And, and uh, in my
sliding glass door in the living room,
I could pull it open and I wanted to put
like a ramp in the living room and ride
a motorcycle,
like often ramp through the sliding
glass door and jump onto the roof of
[inaudible] if you own an
apartment in this motherfucker.
Makes fun of me about them.
What the sliding glass door.
And then because he's like,
this is like a three foot gap
to the building next door.
I like that part was a gimme,
you know, but uh, so I said like,
because I see you guys come over,
bring the fucking camera and this is
what we're going to fucking start filming
jackass three and like a, you know,
get over your comment before I leave,
we're going to do my eviction
party stunts. And uh,
and so basically I scheduled
my own intervention.
Knoxville reached out to doctor drew
who was on the list, the email lands.
He's like, Casey and Steve was like
about to die. And doctor drew said, yeah,
you're right. You know, he said
get over there and fucking,
if you got to tie him up,
put him in the trunk.
Like a take him to the hospital.
Oh and that the other part I've said,
if you don't bring anything for me to
land on, I'm fucking jumping anyway.
I promise I'm ready to die.
So they printed that up.
It was like immediate
threatening my own life,
which qualified me for the 51 50 law
where you can lock someone into a
psychiatric ward.
Wow.
They came over to to for my
intervention and and like,
they're like,
it wasn't like the kind of intervention
where like where they ask if you're
willing to accept help,
you know, it's like,
like we're taking you to the psych ward.
This is what's going to
happen if you don't like it,
we're going to kick your
ass and take you anyway.
So they'd take me to the psych ward for
the 72 hour hold, which is like, you know,
everybody's been on that. Yeah, I
Britney Spears or like, you know,
the whole deal.
But the thing was when we got there,
I was like spitting on people.
I was just like,
not fucking cool and like I was trying
to like throw shit around and you know,
like I'm like when I remember,
cause I thought it was kind of
like calmly explained that it was a
misunderstanding and be out of there.
But like what happened was I,
they had the emails printed out where
I'm like saying I'm ready to die and you
know, and so like they had me, I
wasn't talking my way out of it.
Once I realized I wasn't getting
out of it then a, I'm like fuck,
you know like grab and go to take a
chair and throw it and like I get fucking
tackled by like these orderly dudes,
you know?
And they slammed me onto this fucking
a leg stretch her like bed thing with
straps on it and like someone jabs and
needle and my budget sheet and then I
just straight
like that thorazine shit man.
Like is gnarly man held you
down and whack to with us? Yeah.
They just held me down and fucking
jammed my butt cheek and I was out, dude.
And then I woke up from my
nap and, and uh, I'm in, it
was so funny talking to him.
It was at Cedar Sinai, the
thallium, you know, like, uh,
I mean the Allianz was just the
mental health division or whatever.
So like they have, um, they've
got, they had two wings of the,
of the psych ward there.
Like one,
like they've got the standard issue
harmful to yourself or others, you know,
like committed for the involuntary
psychiatric hold. Then they've got the,
the something else. They the
extraordinarily, you know, like, uh,
the extraordinarily qualifying
individuals, you know, and
the something else wing.
So instead they had me on the
sub the downswing and like, yeah.
And like my roommate
was like fucking like,
like hiding in the closet from like
fucking demons. Oh Dude. It was,
I had been hearing voices
for like a couple of years,
but nothing like this guy
voices say, Oh, do you, oh,
you're the best dog. Like
your cell phone, your back.
I hadn't angels and demons,
you know,
like some of them would tell me like
your woodland's he needed to die and I
would be like trying to suffocate myself
to death, you know, really well. Yeah.
I mean, not like with anything. I'm
just holding my breath. There was a game
that was like, well, you're right.
But that was the whole thing was I was
hearing voices because I was huffing so
much nitris oxide and like while,
while, um, while you're doing ketamine,
while I was doing cocaine,
I never smoked this joint.
Just fucking relax with you in the room.
Right.
I know. You make me feel so
much better about myself.
I used to watch izer watch intervention
so that I could feel better at night.
I'm worried about your health more than
I'm worried about like you overdosing,
you're over. Um, it's,
it's a slow deterioration of your fiber.
Yeah.
Like the stuff that keeps you
together talking. Man, I'm fine now.
I bet right now I feel like I just worked
out and after talking to Steve last
juice in a yoga class,
yeah,
I may.
But whenever like they sent us and I'm
in and something else word like people
are like not people.
One Guy,
I remember one guy like the shit on
the fucking ground and was like break
dancing in it. Right. Try to run.
I mean it sounds like I'm making it
up. I swear I'm not dude. He was,
his goal was to like smear it around
as much as he could.
And this is in the room with you? No, no
that was in the hallway. In the hallway.
It was another dude. It's
breakdancing. Got his own shit.
I mean it looked like it was
break dancing but he was like,
you took a shit and he's trying to smear
it around as much as he could and said,
oh it just looked like
it was break dancing.
Oh my God.
Had me in there because how is,
because I was so belligerent,
I was so belligerent.
They changed my status from (515)
025-0250 which meant they had like,
like 51 50 is three days,
50 to 50 it's two weeks.
So they had me for two weeks and like,
after like four days,
then they moved me over to the,
to the regular psych ward.
And like I was in there and,
um,
this guy who is like a fucking,
he says is a heroin addict and
he's a patient and like he's,
he's got this book about
alcoholism and it's like, dude,
you have, you really like,
this book can really help you. Like
you need this book. And I'm like,
why is it fucking heroin addict given me
a book about alcoholism when we're both
like on suicide watch in a psych ward,
you know, like what's the deal? And,
and I was like, at the point
I was like, I'm like, dude,
I can't, I can't get sober.
I couldn't, you know, I was, I honestly
felt like, like nine and felt like,
I mean like just core belief,
you know,
that like if I could have ever gotten
sober, like I was past that point,
I was too far down the line.
I was a write off a loss cause and like,
so I just, you know, like from when
the fucking first time I was in rehab,
you know,
like there's no chance.
And so like one night I couldn't sleep
and I like some just open this fucking
stupid book, like not to find a solution
but in straight up to kill time,
you know, that's all I'm trying to do and
I'm reading it. It's talking about like,
you know, like hopeless alcoholics
determined to die and this and that.
And then like they, they become like,
you know, they get better or whatever,
you know, they become like the finest men
who could meet and that. And I'm like,
just remember reading
it, thinking like, dude,
what it's saying is like the more
hopeless, the more fucked up you are,
the better the chances for recovery,
which is actually really fully because
if you had like any inkling and I did
like you can manage it,
that you could get better,
that you could stop on your own and
you're just straight up not a candidate.
The Rock bottom theory pretty much.
And it's, it's, it's true, like if, if,
if you feel like you got it are there,
it's not that big of a deal because
he likes for me,
like step one,
we admitted we were powerless over alcohol
or drugs or whatever the case may be.
Like, like, like, and, and that like
that I've successfully did you? No,
like I can't do it. I'm fucking powerless.
And so that's like the first step.
That's like the prerequisite.
And so it's like, I dunno.
And then these guys come in and talk about
alcoholism and I wouldn't have fucked,
never listen to a word they
said, but they like, you know,
but I was locked up in a psych ward
and so I did and I'm like, you know,
thinking there's nothing
I could do about it.
But they told their stories and
how they lived and I'm like, oh,
these guys can do it, you know? And so I
was just like, my life is a fucking mess.
I was in the psych ward long enough to
be like, okay, my life's a fucking mass.
It's time. And I went to
rehab and you know, like,
and so you've been clean for seven and
a half years, just from that moment on,
from the, from that moment on. Yup. Wow.
And there's been any moments where
you're attempted to go off the wagon?
I mean sure, but like, not
like I went from there,
like door to door into like a rehab,
you know? And I remember like,
because I knew from the
fucking back in the day,
like the whole 95 out and percent of
alcoholics don't get sober, like the,
the guy who was in charge of the Rehab and
back then it was Dr drew, like, he was,
he was the, the chemical dependency
director of this hospital in Pasadena.
And, uh, and I was like,
yeah. And I, I told drew,
I said, hey, I said, hey man, you know,
I'm like right on fresh out of
the psych ward. Like, you know,
and I was such a fucking character.
I was like an ad. I'm like, dude,
I know that. Like, I know that, you know,
the odds are not in my fucking favor.
I know, like, I mean I don't want to
waste my time. If I'm going to do this,
I want to get it right.
So I told drew however long you'd
recommend that I didn't mean that I stayed
here. I want to stay significantly
longer cause I want to give myself like,
you know, I want to give myself an
advantage. He said that's great, you know,
but like don't stay here more than
30 days if you're really serious,
go into like a sober living, you know,
like a halfway house kind of a deal. And,
and so I did man. I did everything that
was fucking people do me. I did like, uh,
all the fucking recovery
shit that they talk about.
I did it all and I went to the fucking
sober living and I stayed there until I
had to two full years of sobriety.
I was filming where you stayed
in sober living for 30 years.
I was bouncing around treatment,
um, like uh, for six months,
you know, cause I, cause I was
having a tough time with it.
I just stayed in fucking treatment.
You know.
When you say bouncing around
treatment? Well, I did 30 days there.
Then I went into like a sober
living that doubled. It was like,
it was like sort of mid level care.
So like I was free to go at night as long
as I was home by curfew button all day
long. Right. We had all of our little
groups and like, like you know,
structured rehab activities,
how much is all the should cost.
It's expensive because it was stupid.
Like the 30 days is like a hundred grand.
I'm like, what the fuck? And they
didn't even necessarily know that.
So pay for all this I paid for
with my own money. Oh my God.
So you're just burning through your
savings while you're in there burning
through savings. Yeah. God.
So six months is better than the fucking
seen to $300,000 I spent on fucking
suing like my, these fucking people. I
knew I was going to get nothing out of.
He spent 300 grand suing people that you
knew you were going to get nothing out
of them. I got like my back
catalog. These guys that are,
that I had a distribution deal with.
I got my back catalog of DVDs,
but whatever, that's not worth anything.
It was just a straight resentment.
I just spent three, I just wanted
to fuck their lives up and I did it,
but it cost me 300 grand.
Rehab is a better investment.
So, so while you're in there,
are you working? Hell No.
I ain't no fucking burned all my
bridges, man. You know what I mean?
But we weren't doing anything with Jack
Ass and like anything else I had going
on. Like I had a TV show that, which was
really like, did well in the ratings,
but I was such a fucking nightmare that
they canceled it just on the grounds
that I, they did not want to fuck with
me. I had this spot right after, um,
Monday night raw, the wrestling
on the USA network. Wow.
I came on immediately after
and I kept like a fucking,
a whopping percentage of their viewership.
Dr Steva.
I went around in a fucking,
uh,
modified ambulance with a hot chick
and a fucking 365 pound black football
player,
driver dude,
just trying to deal with sify America
one was he at a time it and I would be
trying to get them to do,
I would except like it submissions where
people would be like, Doctor Steve,
I need your help. Like I, you know,
I'm a whiskey. Like this is my,
my unique and case and I would prescribe
for them some kind of like outrageous,
like jack ass bullshit to make them
come out of their shell or like,
it was good man. Like, uh, I
did a great job problem. Was it,
as soon as the cameras stopped rolling,
I fell off of the radar except for my,
my like uh,
the,
it was a visit with a bunion memory.
The production company, like I did my,
I would be in started like openly
attacking like a John Murray Watt on my,
uh, for 200 people off
on, cause he wasn't,
he wouldn't like pay somebody,
one of my buddies,
something I wanted them to get paid for,
which they did weren't obligated
to fucking pain in the first place.
But I'm trying to ruin his reputation
with like all these, you know,
on my fucking crazy email list.
And that was what that was what killed
the show despite the fact that it was
like number one and
it's fucking time slot.
So I didn't have that fucking to
get to distract me from my recovery
would not cover as you're nothing but
how do you spend your days like when
you're doing that? Well, I mean when
you're in Rehab, Rehab like you,
you got like fucking structured
shit all day long. What do you do?
I mean like different
kinds of groups like a,
they take you out to various kinds
of meetings, you know, like, um,
you got like fucking like a little
therapy bits like uh, you know,
whatever.
It's basically like summer camp and just
everything is geared towards teaching
how to stay sober all day long.
Yeah.
How much can they teach you about
staying? So I'm confused. There's like a,
there's,
there's a lot and I didn't mean a lot
of it's redundant but it's going on for
two years. Oh No, not that
I, this is, I'm talking to,
I'm talking about the first 30.
So the first 30 days it's like teaching
you like coping mechanisms and mostly
just sort of keeping you like,
and it's safe environments were occupied
and drilling into your head that you
can do this and he's like 38 this isn't
going to do shit for anybody because
it's such a slow process,
you know? But, uh,
like it was great for me to stay and
sort of in that environment for two years
because, uh, because you know, then like,
I'm like undisciplined motherfucker,
you know,
by the end of it I was so like,
used to like being up by 9:00 AM with
my bed made like pissing into fucking
plastic cups, like at random, you know,
twice a week like scrubbing the toilet
when it's my turn to scrub the toilet,
you know, like keeping
everything, you know, and, and,
and I did that and when I'm filming
Jackass Three d, I'm like, oh yeah,
like I got to go fucking get washed into
the fucking sky in a Porta potty for a
dog. Shit, I might be a little bit late
for curfew tonight, you know, like,
or whatever, you know, like,
and it had this curfew on the weekdays,
it was 10 and then on the weekends
it was 11 or 12 what or maybe not,
I think it was 11 on the
weekdays and 12 on the weekend.
I think it's hilarious that
after a certain time of night,
like they think you're just going to
get wacky. Well, I mean, whatever,
you can't go to a diner, you know,
what do it saved my life man.
If I can say my life big time and I'm
sure fucking stoked about it. So just the,
the, the, the schedule, the
rigid schedule, the routine.
They had the structure man, the structure
and enjoy in there. Did you have fun?
Did you meet Nice people? I
mean, I remember it pretty well.
My roommate was cool and like he snored,
which was like the fucking greatest thing
ever because I knew when it was cool
to jack off, you know, you know,
it's like the sweet sounds of snoring
or jacking off with the guy in the room.
But if he's snoring it's totally
cool. Yeah. And so that helped
in
the middle of
man, like uh, the, I mean
that helps a lot. If he,
if he didn't snore I a had a tougher time.
Are you allowed to have relationships
where in there are you supposed to like
steer clear thing?
They can sort of any distract you?
I mean there's no like hard
and fast rule about that.
Like they say like avoid getting in a
relationship and your first year I got to
her first year. Yeah, I
got into a relationship.
I mean I like what have you found with
the perfect girl? Yeah. I mean it happens,
it happens, you know, but like
there's just not like, you know,
like relationships gone sideways.
He's like the number one fucking thing
that makes people get loaded. Oh right.
That makes sense. So it's good to like
kind of like, you know, just worry about
your sobriety.
But I had seven months and I got in a
relationship with a chick who had like one
year and it was cool, you know, like
we were last year, like 10 months.
So when you're in there,
you're in there for 30 days,
this is the hardcore version. And then
you go from the 30 days to like, uh,
living situation, a hot and now
how's that? Is that like a house?
Like how's it work? It was like
an apartment complex. That point.
You've got your own apartment then? Yeah,
but I had to park a skate park. Yeah.
That was my thing. I was like, man,
I used to have fucking four
apartments in one building.
Now I got four dudes and one apartment.
So you got to live with other people.
I had a roommate and you know,
there's two,
two bedroom apartment and two guys in the
trout. What? Yeah. And that was the deal.
Why is it the deal? Because they want to
make sure you're not alone by herself.
Do DV Shit. I'd like perhaps, you know,
I guess that's kind of the deal, but
like now what happened? They're like,
and we would have groups from like eight
or nine in the morning until two in the
afternoon and then you're free to go.
And I would be like
skateboarding or whatever,
like trying to film this wacky
shit or whatever, you know,
like I didn't do like much
like in a professional sense.
Um, and I was working with, I was working
on all this like 12 step shit, you know,
so like I get like, uh,
you know, we do like the,
the searching and fearless moral
inventory where like we go through like,
you know, basically like what have we done
that like that we feel are, they went,
like when we make a list of resentments,
make a list of fears and we make a
list of Shit we feel guilty about is
basically how it works.
And like, you know,
I started off with just the shit I
felt guilty about and I'm like, oh,
like I was fine. I just basically wrote
a list of like the shit that I felt like,
you know, the most terrible about it.
And when, when I went through it like,
and this is like tone, if anyone's in
recovery, like avoid like making the,
the system this mistake, I treated
it like I was just like, you know,
putting myself on trial for being
a bad person and like, you know,
the whole point is just to
figure out like what your MD,
take an inventory and like you discard
what's not helpful and you can keep what
is, you know, he's just discontinue shit
that doesn't serve you. But I'm like,
no, I'm a terrible person. I did
this and this and this and this.
And then I'm like, oh fuck. You know,
and like I was just God like winning like
a gnarly depression and felt like I'd
fucking, I don't deserve to
live, you know, like whatever.
And like I fucking checked myself into
a psych ward number two. You know,
while you were in recovery. Yeah,
I had, cause you were going over,
I had like three months of sobriety and
I went to one of my meetings and I was
like,
I was like,
I buy all the work I'm putting
into my fucking recovery on all.
I feel like I'm getting
out of it is self hatred.
I feel like I just can't forgive
myself for this shit. I'm done.
I'm fucking hate myself.
And you know,
and this all came about from just
doing an inventory on your past?
Pretty much. Yeah. I just had
sad like, and it says, you know,
and some of the literature man,
it says it like, you know, uh,
the inventory process we'll like,
you know,
bring about like self loathing for a lot
of people when we take an honest look
at like the fucking pieces of shit
that we became like that's like a,
a not an uncommon side
effect, you know, like
what sort of tools they give you
to look at your past but not,
not be angry at yourself,
not judge yourself.
Well, I mean, I don't know. I like it.
Like when I'm helping guys get sober,
I try and tell him, look man, this isn't
a process of putting you on trial, man.
This is just if I can figuring
out what to stop doing now.
And that's the best
thing I can say about it.
But when I was in that second psych
ward, like, uh, you know, I was like,
like I wrote,
I wrote some letters to people who have
felt the most fucked up about what I'd
done, you know, and like, and it actually
kind of turned around where I was like,
you know,
I wasn't like today I'm
fucking so thankful for the
shit that I did that I felt
that bad about it because
like, no longer is it like, oh,
I don't deserve to live because
I did that for me today.
It's like I'm fucking desperate to not be
that fucking asshole anymore, you know?
And so I turned into, you know,
and like when I first went in,
I was like the kind of thought like,
man, this is going to be my new thing.
I'm going to get sober. And like, you
know, I'm going to be like, you know,
the world's going to kind of, Oh man, I'm
going to revive my career a little bit.
But once I got through that point of like,
you know,
like Sorta the fucking, uh, you know, the,
the dust settling and me being able to
maybe being confronted with what I had
turned into then it wasn't even about
what can I get out of it, you know,
it was just about I don't want
to be that fucking guy anymore.
And so I came out of that second rehabber
that's second psych ward and I was so
desperate to not be that fucking piece
of shit anymore. And I was like, dude,
I'm starting over. And I went into the
fucking, like, I went into another rehab,
like the fuck and, and guide the
hardcore, you know, and I was just like,
I'm doing this to be an I.
Like I had my priorities straight,
you know? And then I was there
for 60 days and I've been said,
by the time I finished
that it was six months.
And then I went into like the
regular sober living and so the,
there's a lot of fucking money
you're spending here. Yeah. The, the,
the last Rehab was seven,
a 7,500 per month.
So at least, uh, I, but yeah,
fucking it was like 30
grand that second rehab.
I heard of the second psych ward.
I spent a lot of money on it, man.
Fucking whatever. What are the guys
that you were in the apartment with?
What did those guys do for a living, but
they can't afford to live in this shot.
I paid the rent and I paid him age,
like 1000 bucks a month to do nothing.
Why did you pay him money
for what? Well, one guy was,
you said that like he was on call to edit
whatever footage like that, you know,
that uh, the, that I wanted edited,
like to help me broadcast my
downward spiral basically. You know,
like I put some really upsetting videos.
All the people that you were living in
the assisted situation like this is post
the major rehab,
right?
You were in the major rehab for three
days and then you'll be a part of the
brain. There's different levels of,
of uh, of rehabbing. Yeah. Like, um,
yeah and, and I wound up like back in,
yeah. I mean it was in the whole deal.
At one point I was in a house for a
while and then sharing a bedroom with the
guy who snored and you know,
and I, and I, and, and you know,
at the end I was in the apartment,
but it was all the same deal.
What did these guys do for living that
they could afford to like take all this
time off of the sober living
situation was like, uh,
like that was like 1000 bucks
a month. And that covers like,
uh,
your meals as well.
So it's kind of more cost effective
than if you're going to try and find an
apartment or anything like that
in the sober living situation.
It's like these guys worked during the
day and they would come there and stay
with you. If you don't work, you have
to do a certain number of hours of, uh,
of service work. So I would
volunteer at a nursing home. Whoa.
Yeah. It was dope man.
Like, uh, I would just go,
I'd go fucking hang out with old people
and pleading, I'd call the Bingo numbers.
Yeah.
And then,
and then I would like go and
fucking film a movie for paramount.
Like I'd be like, oh, hey guys,
I'm not going to be able to call Bingo
tomorrow because I'm going to be like
drinking a fat guys sweat.
So when did it feel like you were free
of the monkey when the phone was laying?
Never free of the mind can ever
right now you're not free. I mean,
whenever like,
um,
I just have like a way that
I live my life, you know,
that um, I still stay connected. It's
like a fridge man. You know? Like, uh,
if you unplug the fridge and then
everything and it's going to go rotten,
you know,
like you got to fucking stay plugged
in, which means that like these
things that, that we do to stay sober.
Like you just fucking keep doing well,
like helping other people stay sober.
It's like the biggest thing,
you know, like, you know,
you take people through their 12 steps
that you take through and you know them I
may or whatever, like you meet them sort
of in the community, you know, like a,
they'll ask you like, will
you be my sponsor? You know,
when you have a sponsor they call you
up in the middle of the night. Hey,
I'm thinking about doing heroin. Like
that kind of thing. Talking about that,
that is the idea. It's better to
call before you do it and then after,
cause there's no point in
talking to a load of dude.
And how often do you do this?
Like how often you work with,
uh, I mean it depends. Like most guys
like aren't like that active where there,
where they actually really call
a lot. But like, uh, you know, I,
I'm always starting a guy, you
know, there's always guys I,
I'm starting off and just very few of
them stick with it where they get the guys
have taken all the way through the steps.
There's been two,
two out of how many,
oh my God.
Well over a hundred. So a hundred people,
two of them would become totally sober.
Um,
I mean they've been like a
say totally sober. I mean you're totally
sober and as long as you're younger,
not loaded right now. Um,
one guy got all the way through the steps,
but then he's, he's drinking again. So,
you know,
I got one,
I got one guy that's been all the way
through the steps that still in do you
think,
are you one of those people that thinks
that if you were a junkie that you have
to be sober forever? Like you can't,
you can't go back to, like you say,
if you had a heroin problem, you can't
drink it. Say once he become a pickle,
you never go back to being a cucumber.
So yeah, like, like, uh, like there's
no, if I pick up a drink or I'd drag,
I'm fucked.
If I decided I'll pick up
exactly where I left off.
But I know that all I want is like to
make sure I'm doing enough drugs that
people are walking around my
fucking apartment in my house,
the who are not actually there.
But I know people that used to be like
heroin addicts that can have beer.
They can smoke a little wind,
they can get away with it, man.
Then then power to them.
It's dangerous.
Why is it dangerous though? I mean,
if they're free of it, like, okay,
here's a perfect example. Anthony
Bordain. He was a heroin addict.
He was a junkie full on,
you still look to have a beer.
He looks to Jim doesn't drink at home.
Perry Farrell I think is like that.
You know, you can't have heroin, a
debate, drinks, wine or whatever. Hey man,
power to him.
But uh,
but for you it's not a
long line alcoholics man.
Like the way that my family is
structured, there might, my lineage,
like dad was like a broken mold
of his fam. Dad comes from right
line of,
of like
academics, like PhDs,
scholars, theologians,
zoologists
like, and he broke the mold of his family
by becoming a businessman and a super
successful one at that
Mom's side of the family.
Everybody is alcoholic and drug addict,
gambler and suicide.
How'd your mom and dad, me, um, pardon?
She was super hot. You know, like,
um, but yeah, so like every,
I mean everybody in my mom's side of
the family is either dead or dying from
alcoholism. I would say I, me and
my cousins, I guess, I don't know.
My one cousin is a mortician.
Yeah.
I went to clown college,
I went to clown college.
He went to mortician school at the
same time. Went to clown college,
Ringling brothers and Barnum and Bailey
clown college for real. Yeah. You do.
This is an exploding
shoe. Well, like whenever,
like I said,
I left the University of Miami.
I wanted to become a
crazy stunt man and a,
and all I really accomplished
like with that, you know,
even with all my crazy skills
is drinking bottled water.
Like I couldn't get a job like,
and uh,
and so she was like
homeless for three years.
He's getting arrested and fucking
hospitalized almost for three years.
While I was couch surfing for three years,
I had the government has money or to
try and test drugs on me for money.
And I mean,
they do medical studies for like a,
they'd be medical studies for whatever,
you know,
like if it's going to come in
contact with the human body,
like if it's a toothpaste or something,
they've got to do a medical study,
but if it's a toothpaste and
you're not going to get paid shit,
if it's fucking drugs for pigs and cows,
then then you're going to get the,
based on how dangerous the study is,
the more money you get.
And so I wouldn't sign up for to have
drugs for pigs and cows touching on me,
which I, which I recently
found out the drugs was banned.
Jesus fucking Christ is like,
this was in like 19 the in January of
94 you're like a house that you like,
you get to the back. When woke
we this the last door. Hold on.
Oh Jesus. A whole nother house.
Yeah, it was like they, they,
they want like the, you
know, 1994 like whatever,
the January of [inaudible]
94 and they had,
they wanted to pass this drug through
the FDA called ractopamine hydrochloride.
And the goal of that,
they didn't know much about it.
Said they knew they would make the
cattle like a more lean like a,
it wouldn't like increase the muscle mass,
decreased the fat so and but it would
work the opposite way of steroids somehow.
And like there was so that they could
appeal to a more kind of health conscious
and market. They could sell like
leaner meat, you know, less fat.
But the thing is that if it's going to
become legal then like by the virtue of
the fact that when people eat the meat,
they're going to get like a minute trace
of this drug in the, in the, you know,
the meat.
Now they have to not only test the drug
on people but they have to test like how
much can the people withstand shock.
So like they knew them,
they knew that it was going
to like increase our heart
rates. Like uh, you know,
and so what they,
the,
the target for this study was to give it
to us until somebody in this study had
their resting heart rate.
Like laying down, resting.
I'm like 150 beats a minute,
like,
um,
and it turned out that I had like the
fucking most bad ass hard in the study.
Like the only time I went over a hundred
was when the guy like monitoring my
heart with like the ultrasound
thing and then, you know, like, uh,
the show the baby on the screen.
Like I,
he was like telling me stories about like
killing people in Vietnam or some shit.
He was like, if some
like, uh, you know, yeah.
It was like God told me like war stories
and that got my heart like, uh, you know,
I'll have a normally like, like what
kind of stories? I can't remember.
It was just like he was in the war and
he killed people and I was telling you
what he's doing an ultrasound of your
heart. Yeah. And it's the same guy,
the same guy when he was looking at it,
showed like your blood,
like going in your heart like a red and
coming out of your heart blew like on
the screen. It was really
fucking cool. And, uh, and I
just had like a strong heart,
you know, she's like me. He said, man,
what a squeeze, you know, like eat out.
Like what a squeeze. I got two guys. Yeah.
And I was, I was homeless anyways, so
like they LG g I did that in Austin,
Texas too. Yeah. That was an Austin,
Texas at this place called Pharmaco Lsr
second. I told you I got in the van,
that guy, and we drove ads
in northern California to a,
to Lake Tahoe to try and get jobs,
Washington dishes at squaw valley
to get free snowboard passes,
but it wasn't snowing.
So then we went to fucking Colorado and
I got a job like cleaning a meat room at
a supermarket and that sucked.
So I'll go one with this other
dude and drove to Austin,
Texas and slept on a roof until
we got into the medical study.
And then we left with two grand and we
were stoked. And then like, you know,
end up like getting a car and following
the grateful dead and selling drugs.
And Geez, my gosh. And I was homeless
for like three years. And, um,
and like periodically I'd get my hands
on cameras and do really fucked up shit.
But you know, I was getting video footage
but like ultimately like, you know,
I just fucking, it was really
bombed dude. It wasn't,
I didn't like after three years
I couldn't take any more night.
I reached out to my sister and she led
me move in with her and Albuquerque and I
was like, I would eat all her
food and I wouldn't fucking work.
I had no money and if I did have money,
I was loaded and I was loud
and I was like, you know,
so when my sister found out about Ringling
brothers and Barnum and Bailey clown
college, she's like, dude,
this could be the way to get my
brother the fuck out of my house. Like,
so like she told me about it.
Like I got home and she's like,
how are you getting to Denver by Monday?
And I,
I hitchhiked from Albuquerque to Denver
and I got there in two rides and just
fucking went ape shit. If you've
written a book. Uh Huh. Okay.
Is this all in the book? Totally.
Did my blood and my books.
I got it barely made the New
York Times bestseller list.
That's because you didn't come on
here first. Probably. Yeah, I can.
If people had heard these fucking
stories and knew that they were in the,
oh my God barely made the best
New York Times bestseller list.
But what I'm most proud of my book,
cause my masterpiece man, like um,
on Amazon it's got like the,
the,
the key middle of average rating is
a four or five out of five stars.
There's fucking partial
starts. Even people who hate
me and want to hate my book,
give it a fucking fives. Tried it
yourself. I've worked with a writer on it,
but uh,
but I don't think anybody has like been
more involved in the collaboration.
Like we bounced, we bounced out that
shit back and forth. I'm like, dude,
I would never use that word.
I don't, you know, like I,
I worked my dick off on that fucking book.
Your stories fucking insane.
It's like, it just has layers
upon layers, you know? That's,
and that's kind of like, what's dope
about the fucking like the, the,
the comedy show man. I'm just like really
bombed, like to retire like my shit,
you know, like how you retiring?
What do you mean? Well, you know,
like you were tired material once
the fucking special comes out. Yeah.
We make new stuff.
Of course want to be cartoony for growth.
Right?
You want to be a comedy factory,
not a comedy warehouse when we look at it.
Yeah.
That's the only way to look at your comedy
should kind of represent who you are
right now. Well, yeah,
and that's why 20 years ago it doesn't
really represent who you are. Right.
Of course. Like the whole like,
I don't fucking, like I told you,
it's like the history is like super
condensed, you know, like, uh, you know,
so it's like funny.
And with the story points I like on
story points I have like when I say like
about how graduated from Ringling brothers
and Barnum and Bailey clown college,
but like I wasn't one of the clowns who
got fucking contract with the circus
side, like borrow money to get a fucking
greyhound bus back to Albuquerque,
New Mexico where I hung my fancy clown
costume in the fucking closet and sold
shitty weed and the bags of fucking weed
I sold did not weigh anywhere near what
they were supposed to weigh in my
life. Fucking sucked. Really bad, bad.
After I got done ripping you off,
like at least I would show you like a
fucking epic. Unbelievable cool trick.
Like this one. And then like on that
point like, well fucking bring the,
bring the thing like the table out and
I'm going to fucking show you the most
incredible bar chick ever. So when did
you, when did you put this book out?
A 2011 did you go on the full tour?
Do all these radio shows and I mean,
I did like radio tour, like a, I'd never
went on Howard Stern, like, uh, we'll see.
That must have helped. Yeah. I mean
it didn't do like terrible, you know,
but just like you need like a platform
where you could just talk for hours and
hours and hours. Right. It'd be cool
if I had like a podcast too. I just,
like you were saying, right, ma'am, I'm
everybody's tired of Comico and dude,
you should have a podcast, right? So
t shirt that says, dude, you should
have a podcast. So I've said it to
so many people, but does anybody,
like a lot of those fucking
people took you up on it?
Not every podcast, just the Joe Rogan
experience. Did, you know, like,
it's the most fucking annoying question
ever. Like, Hey, will you do my podcasts?
You know, when you get cornered by your
body and like, yeah, some people were,
they did not. But it's one of those
things we got to kind of work at it.
It doesn't seem like
you have to work on it,
like standards standup
sort of the same way.
Of course we're doing
kill Tony last night.
It's one of the things
I wanted to tell people.
Like it seems like it's just you talking,
but you have to figure out how people
are perceiving you and, and that's,
that's a big part of doing a podcast too.
But you would be really good at it.
It would be good man. He just did
like one a week. You'd probably,
it would take you a year or two
to run out of stories. I, I mean,
not even necessarily like who knows if
like if you're going to tell us stories
about shit that happened or what's
going on. Yeah. Man, this dude.
Do you have like a guy that you could do
it with? We could bounce shit off them.
Do you have a good buddy that you
thought about? Like, well with,
I've thought about doing it,
you know, there's this fucking
platform, this uh, this,
um,
which we call it a,
it's caught you now and one
of these streaming things
like periscope or Meerkat,
but like,
fuck dude,
this is so crazy like you now.
And like everybody who is
a user of this platform,
I kept like, it has an account
that they like put money into.
And so the way it works is
like why you're streaming leg,
like their questions show up and they
want to get an answer to their question.
So they'll like,
they have like different denominations
of like money that they like give you
like cam girl.
Now I swear dude,
my agents, my agents like, like bullied
me into doing it and I've tried it right.
And I just sat there like just tell him
stories to like the fans that were on
fucking watching and my by the end,
but I was on there for like 39 minutes
and then I fucking ended the stream.
And it's like you just made $1,000
felt like a fucking pan handler
is very cam girl ask. Yeah.
But if you did that all the time,
it would probably at least pay for
a studio if you set up a studio.
So I mean for sure, but
you don't want, see,
you don't want to people to have to
pay to ask you questions. Like I said,
it felt like a fucking panhandler.
I hate it and I haven't done
it since I did this show.
And the guy who promoted the
show, uh, I didn't know about it.
Something to Brian counts set up. This
guy, that guy, what a fucking guy.
But this guy had set it
up and I love Brian Tube.
He doesn't pay attention to shit.
It's not like real good with details.
I had to ask them a bunch of questions
about the shell. Like, hey man,
there's a guy who's a Dj who is saying
that he's spinning records in between us
a week. Is there a fucking break in
between us? Where does a DJ come on? Ah,
I'll check. I'll check. It's just you and
I. I get there. It's not just me and him.
It's me.
Him does a fucking MC three local comics.
A girl's doing 20 minutes
and it was a disaster.
We had to clean up this giant mask. It's
podcasts. No, no, no. It's a comedy show.
But anyway,
the guy had made people pay extra to take
pictures to meet us and take pictures.
Exactly. And I said, do you can't do that?
I would never, I would never do that.
And you can't do that. You can't do that.
It's fun. I take pictures with everybody.
I'll do a theater and I'll wait for
hours and I'll show you pictures with a
thousand fucking people. Like you
can't charge people an extra 20 bucks.
Take pictures of me on his own.
He did it on his own as a promoter,
and this is all shit that calendars
didn't pay attention to the way,
the way I do that. And, and Ryan's cool
about taking pictures as well. Yeah, no,
he was totally cool.
He just didn't pay attention.
He just let this guy
handle everything we will.
Who we did need in the first place. You
know, what do you, what do you need?
He's doing it. We don't need a promoter.
This is Twitter. That's the promoter,
you know, let people know you're there.
They show up. It's not that hard.
Like what does this promoter in
quotes doing, what is he doing?
He's just trying to get his friends on
the show and trying to charge extra to
take pictures.
It was stupid but that's a gross model.
Like the model of like people having to
pay for VIP entrance or all that gross
shit and meet and greet the,
um,
the one thing that is the cell phone
pictures like take fucking forever.
So what I do is I have my,
my website where I'd take the pictures
of myself and like when when the fucking
I'm so good at it and I stole your idea.
We stole that.
Jamie comes with me to some shows and
takes pictures and we thought that it's
better. Yeah, it takes way quicker.
It's like one third the time better
too if you take them yourself.
Because that way when the flash goes off,
you turn the camera around and you can
show the people their pictures so they
can see it for like,
why do the quality control,
don't let him say it because then they'd
go, oh my God, take that again. Oh my God,
I do it.
Oh my God.
Cause girls who like looking at photos
of themselves and everything's great.
Like, oh my God, I hate that picture.
Do it again. Yeah. But no, no, no.
This is what you look like. Yeah. But
that's the thing is that like for me like,
uh, I I my cameras so fast that
you're like, oh no. Okay, boom.
I half the time Alan like, oh you
don't like it, I don't like it.
So I'll take another one.
Whatever invite might be picky and
I don't like the way my teeth look.
So, so the fucking like, um,
and I just wanted the people
to and be really like Hap,
I getting a bunch of cheese fry man.
Like,
I want them to be super happy with it
because I know that when they fucking go
to my website and pull it did,
they're going to post it on their fucking
all their social media and I know that
they're going to post it. And
then, yeah. And then that's,
that's sort of my grassroots
way of letting people know
what the fuck I'm doing.
Yeah, no, it's smart move. And I started
doing it right after I heard you did it.
I think Brian told me about it.
And a bunch of people do that now.
It's April does that too,
right? It doesn't. Gabriel
Garcia to something like that.
Similar to a smart,
right at the end of
every show I said, okay,
now I'm going to like, uh,
before I do my last fucking amazing stone,
I'm going to do,
I want to thank you guys for coming out
and giving me a shot at stand up and you
know, I'm going to fucking, when I walk
off the stage, I'm not going anywhere. Um,
so I'd take a photo with every single
one of you guys and here's how you get
them to go to my fucking website.
And I explain it really easy and I say it.
And one last thing, if you want to
get out of here a little quicker,
the good news is I'm a New York Times
bestselling author and I've got my fucking
my book and I've got my fucking,
like my hats, my shirts,
and if you guys want to
get any of this shit,
then that puts you to the front of the
lions have been emerge line and then a
photo.
So like,
so there's so many merge line first to
get to the photo for the gift shop and
it's like, it's fucking
Disneyland. That's the thing.
I'm still going to take a picture
with every single fucking person.
It's just having to take a picture of
the people or by March 1st you know?
And so like a lot of people would,
would be like, oh well fuck man. Like,
I don't want to, you
know, and I tell him egg,
if you don't want to get
anything that's great,
but please just let me hang
out and like have a drink,
whatever lipid and just fucking stick
around and get that picture so I can thank
you in person. And a lot of people
will think like, man, like, you know,
I want to get a picture.
You know,
it wasn't no really want to
buy anything but like fuck it.
I'll just buy something to
get the fuck out of here.
So you ended up selling like
way more merged, you know,
and nobody feels like you're a dick.
You know,
he's still stick around and take a photo
with every, every one in the fuckers.
The only problem was sewing things is
you got a deal with people like $20 dude.
Like those people like oh right,
but how many,
how many people are out there by
selling fucking a one fucking side,
one color fucking shirt for 35 40 bucks.
Like Andrew dice clay.
So it smells like a fucking
one color screen. Five shirts.
He actually brings like five shirts and
he auctions them off. Oh, I don't know.
I never heard about that. Shirts for
like $500 and I mean, and that's,
yeah, I charge, I charge
20 bucks for, for whatever,
but I sign every last fucking the,
should I say like, hey, you know,
you can have a five star in New York
Times bestseller that's autographed by the
author and a picture and 20 bucks.
I don't feel bad about it. No. Look,
it's great for a book for
20 bucks is a great deal.
You think about the amount of time it's
caused book about a time that you spend
being entertained by that book,
the greatest bargain ever. Yeah,
I lost take days to read, you
know? Yeah. I love that shit man.
But in any case, I'm so sideman that you
have like as much of a reach as you did,
man,
because I really,
we got to fucking get this paramount
theater in Austin fucking packed, man.
I'm going to like, that show is
going to be like, that's why.
That's why I show times to leave here
and your phone's going to be buzzing off
the hook with your manager going.
Did you say you going to
light the paramount on fire?
It's a huge stage.
And like, dude, they told me one time
to get out of the room. Don't worry,
everybody will eat you alive.
No great white.
There was like 23 people that
just died recently. Fire on stage.
It just happened again. We're two
people in the band even died where uh,
yeah, it's just like great whites. Uh,
it was it Sweden or something happened.
It's sparked on the side stage and
immediately the whole place caught on fire
wait techniques. Pyrotechnics.
Dude, it's not worth it.
We used to have those in the UFC.
We just have these fucking giant
like opening shows. Actually,
I don't think we had, yeah, we did
have fire believe, but uh, in, um,
Joel de Oliveira,
I was like,
it's a famous fighter from Brazil
and he was fighting in pride and they
accidentally lit them on fire and uh,
he was on his way to the,
to the ring and you know,
they do the boom when you're
walking through like this gateway,
they liked the fight and they,
they fucked up the timing.
They lit this fucking dude on fire as
he's on his way into the ring and burnt
them. And then they said, oh, you'll be
back me give you a more money. And so,
you know,
it took like a year off,
healed up his fucking
18 degree burns and uh,
I came back a year later and fought again.
Do you have anything,
like when you go to the doctor, do you
have anything that that bothers you?
You still to this day from like a done,
I know you have like a kb and your
like baby's stuck in my body but I,
that's by choice. I have,
uh, you know, I mean
like big teeth and shitty
tattoos is most of it,
but I'm like in my esophagus is fucked.
What's wrong,
what you're talking
in the car.
I got Barrett's esophagus.
It's like, you know,
like what are the warning signs for
esophageal cancer and from just like,
like acid reflux and I don't know,
drugs and shitty living and vomiting.
Do you, are you dude, take care
of yourself now? I got an idea.
I'm going in for an endoscopy. Cigarettes
smoked in. And you're a vegetarian now,
right? Yeah. Vegan. You haven't
smoked in seven years. Wow.
So when you start getting sober,
I was five months separate when
I gave up cigarettes. Oh, okay.
And I haven't smoked weed
and since March 9th of 2008.
So I'm no coffee for not
smoking weed for this one. Oh,
no worries man. I appreciate
it. No worries. I wouldn't,
wouldn't want to get you
secondhand lambasted,
although some people keep
telling me that's bullshit,
but I know it's not enough hot.
Like,
I don't really give a fuck
if people drink around me,
but like the weeks I'm like
breathing it in and like,
it's like the problem is it
fucking smells great man.
He doesn't love the smell of weed.
Smells great and it,
I do believe secondhand
smoke gets you hot.
I don't think it gets
you as high smoking pot,
but I think spec secondhand
smoke still affects you.
I don't even want to fuck with it.
Makes Sense. Super grateful. So,
um, oh yeah, no Vegan.
There's a whole
other fucking like a major other door
and there's this, I mean I'm going to
fucking let people didn't see this,
you know, at in Austin or at the
show time, but it's like, you know,
I it fucking go to rehab and
like get sober in the whole
deal and then it's like,
all right,
one,
it's great that I've learned how to
live without fucking drugs and alcohol,
but like now I'm going to
address my sex addiction
used to die that he followed her. You'll
travel with a professional cock blocker.
Yeah, I got, I mean, that was my deal
dude. Like, I was like, you know,
and this is a, it's a mean joke, I
tell, but you know, I say I'm like,
I'm fucking 41 now and I'm looking
at my future and you know, like,
I don't want to be 51 and falling apart
and trying to hump everything that moves.
I don't want to turn into Pauly shore.
I mean, if there's a guy, but, uh,
I'm sure there's a few other guys,
it's be fucking ride that
boat right into the rocks.
But the thing is, right,
right. I just like, honestly,
man, it was like, fuck dude.
Like I, you're married,
right? And in psych,
I really believe that,
like to be happy, you know,
like it's,
it's important to have fucking,
I have a life partner and knocked the
run around trying to fuck everybody and
screwing them over it. You know, like,
that's the deal. Like, I like, well,
how can I gives so much of a fuck about
animals and I won't fucking eat an
animal, but I have no respect
for women at all. You know,
like it doesn't add up like,
so it like on my fucking path.
And once I got into the meditation,
like I've been doing
transcendental meditation for
two and a half years now and
like, I couldn't, you know, once I got
into that, like it was just like glaring,
like a fucking flashing red light,
like stop fucking screwing over chicks,
you know? And, and fucking using him up
and throwing them away and just like,
you know, like, and
whatever, if I'm on the road,
like fuck a hooking up with
all the chicks, it's just
like, it just became clear,
like that's pretty much like a
path to being fucking miserable.
And it's a type of addiction.
Yeah, for sure. Because I get,
it's like anything else. So I'd like, you
know, I made myself a promise, like, okay,
if now on,
I'm like,
I want to fucking learn how to be in a
healthy relationship because I feel like
that's how I'm going to be happy. And so
I'm going to fucking from here on out,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna fuck random checks on that.
I'm not gonna stop trying to get my
dick sucked everywhere. You know,
I like that. I can do it, man.
[inaudible] gonna Rehash and
30 days like I could do it,
you know, one step at a time. 12 days
go walk up the fucking stage.
I'm not to go anyway and type,
take a picture with everybody.
Right.
So the whole fucking audience basically
gets in align and it's an audition to
see who gets to suck my Dick that
I'm,
I fucking to the whole the whole thing.
I mean I remember like that guy gets his
dick sucked. No, cause he's a fucking,
he's in the fucking sex program to program
and there's a whole program he needs
somebody to oversee both of you guys. I
mean, whatever. Like, I'm stoked, man,
because now I'm like
fucking, you know, I'm like,
I've gotten therapy like the whole deal
and which is hilarious because like,
you know, my whole story arc, you know,
it's like, it's, it's pretty epic,
you know, to, to go from where I was
at to where I'm at now. You know,
at the end,
I think at the end of the show I'm going
to have to fucking break out my old
light bulb trick and fucking slash my
shit and bleed everywhere just because,
just,
just because like to
fucking try to fucking,
like by the end of blag my fucking show,
it's like a case now I'm like a
fucking Vegan and eh, you know,
like trying not to get my Dick's know,
like clean and sober,
like fucking hell. The eater, you know,
meditating like the least I can do is
fucking bleed all over myself out too.
I can do it. You're a Vegan because you
love animals. That's how I got into it.
Yeah,
but you feed your animals animals.
I do feed my dogs dog food
that has fish in it and I just,
I just adopted a cat and the same thing,
they just don't like the fuck. They just
don't fucking like Vegan dog food. I did.
It's terrible. I did it
for awhile. They to be,
they have to be like,
like at the point of hunger where like
you're willing to eat your own fucking
foot. Isn't that kind
of fucked up? You know,
it's like you're choosing
the animals that you love.
You're feeding these animals, other
animals that were captive. I mean,
if you want to be like super
black and white, like p,
then I mean that's the reality of animals,
right? I mean, I just like that. Like,
I dunno. I mean I hear that like the,
and even in my fucking canvas,
you know,
slip on vans that there's some kind
of animal products in the rubber
rubber.
Like I'm not gonna not get photographed
because there's animal products. The,
in the film, you know, you just can't,
you can't do everything a hundred
fucking percent. You know, like a,
I just do the best I can and
I feel better. I feel better
for doing it. Yeah, no,
it's,
it's the,
the animal thing is weird when people
are super self righteous about killing
animals. And yet that's for sure. I've,
I've had a real issue with that with
people cause I get it man. And that's why,
that's why like I'm like really fucking
committed to not try to tell other
people what to do. You know, I don't have
your whopper man. I don't care. Like,
you know what I mean? You
want, I don't give a fuck.
I'm just happier in myself like,
you know,
trying to do and why and what about like
farm fresh eggs or things along those
lines where nothing gets
going and I was fucking with,
with fish and eggs for like a while
and I want to hang around with the only
reason they went back to being
fully Vegan, but um, you know,
was cause I'm fucking tired all the
time and I'm like, man, what is it?
I think it's my diet and I
think if I eat fish and eggs,
then all of a sudden I'll have more
energy. But it didn't happen now.
And then I fucking had a sleep study.
It turns out I've got sleep apnea,
so can I do to, it was never my Jesus
c pap machine. No, I use a mouth piece.
I didn't see how I tried to see
pap and I can't fucking do it.
And so now I've got to get the mouthpiece.
I'll turn you on to a doctor that's,
that makes a really good one. A
lot of, um, people that have it.
It's your tongue for I have a fat
tongue and neck and I was not,
I went to this,
uh,
physician to get cleared
for a TV show and uh,
she was shining the light in
the back of my third. She said,
do you feel like you sleep a whole night
and wake up and you're still tired?
I'm like, yes. She says, what? Then the
back of your throat, it's really narrow.
And then she thinks, and I think
that's going to cause of sleep apnea.
The holes narrow. Yeah, I have that too.
And also like I that they've talked to
me about getting an an operation when
they take out your adenoids and your
tonsils and it's pretty intense and it's,
it's,
it sucks for like a week but then after
it's over you have a larger hole and
that larger holes better for sleeping.
But this serves me well.
Do you still get up to Piss as
much? Oh if I have to Piss, if I,
I try not to drink before I go to
bed like right before I go to bed.
But if I do this a lot and drink
a lot lately I've been trying,
I got to fucking big fucking water pitcher
next to my bed on the floor so I just
picked up a piss into
it and put it back down.
My friend Matt Serra who was former UFC
welterweight champion when I first met
him,
he had this gym in Long Island and he
used to sleep in the basement of his gym,
which is teach and then
go downstairs and sleep.
And I hear this jug right next to the bed
cause fighters will drink like gallons
of water. You drink water all the
time to flush your system out.
And he would just whip his dick out, stick
it in the hole. He healed his accent.
He goes, I didn't even get out
of bed. I would turn sideways,
put my Dick in the whole piste
pull it out, put the Jug.
Now went back to I did so great man.
This one was a water pitcher.
Like I don't have a very
big dick or anything,
but like I don't even really have to
like tip over man because like it's got
like a about things like one of
those classic Koolaid fucking
cool. It breaks through
the wall, the Koolaid kind.
So I just flip flop my deck. Good to
go. So when you got to sleep study,
they put all the electrodes on you times.
Did you whoa,
wake up in an hour. They said that it was
actually like mild to moderate, but uh,
but still, I mean I noticed
it dude, I'm fucking,
I got to get that fucking mouthpiece.
It's not, well, you should lose weight.
I need to do in weight as the big one I
think with Joey d is Joey Diaz uses the
CPAP machine,
but he
didn't use to have to have that.
It's like when he got really big,
that's when he really developed
because the more fat you have,
it's all closed as everything off.
You know when you see people with
giant jowls would guess what that fat's
everywhere.
It's inside your face.
It's inside your neck and all that fat
will close off the whole and when you lay
back and your tongue falls over that
whole, there's no air and just right.
I had to wake the guy up,
man, I was on a plane.
This fucking guy was not breathing for
like minutes at a time and then and then
gagging and coughing and that.
I'm wake them up,
but I talked to him when he
woke up and I said, hey man,
have you ever gotten checked
for sleep apnea? Because he was,
he was snoring the most ungodly
so funny man, but it wasn't like
always a snow. I'm thinking,
you're saying motherfucker, wake
on. I'm not snoring. He's like, oh,
like caring about the guy. It's like when
he said like, I'm thinking like, man,
I'm going to get sued.
Like you're not worried about the
kid who's got spiked on his head.
You're a good guy. I try to be, it
was freaking me out because
he was making these noises
and then he would go back to like,
and then it would be nothing,
no sound. And uh, I'm,
I'm awake because I was writing and it
was on a long flight and I looked over at
this guy and I'm noticing that he's,
he's very overweight and it's just
lying there. Like there's no movement,
no breathing, no, no movement at
all in his chest. Then all of sudden
like, I mean, he would go, I mean
I'm exaggerating when I say minutes,
but he would definitely go 40 seconds.
Like I timed it,
I forget what the time was,
but I remember being alarmed and
I remember sitting up going, okay,
I got to talk to this guy.
And I had my mouthpiece with me
cause I bring it in my bad moods.
Your lower jaw forward. Oh,
no, no, no. Mine doesn't.
Mine actually just depresses my tongue
down and it keeps my tongue from falling
back over my air hole problem.
It depends on what kind of sleep apnea
as that central one. I think they said.
Hmm. I don't know what's the
difference? I don't know.
Joey would know more than anyone
because Joey's got it real bad.
Joey needs the CPAP, like he has to have
air blow in this whole, I love that.
I love him too. It's probably smoking weed
right now in Paris. Go back. Um, but uh,
anyway,
so I,
the guy was like kind of stirring and
moving and when he finally was like
opening his eyes and looking around,
I talked to him and I had like
a long sit down with them.
I showed them the mouthpiece, I'm going
to go, dude, you could die. I go, you,
you hold your,
I was going to film it,
but I thought there would be rude
to just film you. But I mean,
you're holding your
breath for a long time.
If you ever talked to anyone
about it. He's like, no, you know,
my wife tells me I snore. I
go, dude, you don't just snore.
You like choking to death.
You know?
And there's a lot of people that you
don't know what happens when you go to
sleep. You're out and you sleep, you're
out. And when you're out like that,
you're not getting any oxygen. When you
sleep, you don't get into heavy rem sleep.
You're going to get
into those deep cycles.
You just skirt the edges and then you
wake up because your body's gasping and
panic mode.
And so you'll wake up after like eight
of sleep and he's still fucking exhausted
every day. I feel like I could go
back to bed or right when I wake up.
You really could, should lose weight.
I mean, you know, that's a big,
that's its social Joey. Joey mean this
is a big thing with Joey's way, way,
way overweight. Yeah. And he got down
a while just like you did. I mean,
Joey lost like 80 fucking pounds
at one point. But um, he's,
he gets energy from that c-pap.
Like he feels way better.
Like he travels with one.
He has this machine that he travels with,
then he has to check.
I mean,
so he always has to check his
luggage because his carry on his,
his c pap machine. So he doesn't go
anywhere without checking his luggage.
Every flight he takes joy. He brings that
machine with him. That is his fucking,
that's his security system.
You brought up earlier,
you brought up Greg Fitzsimmons because
Cosby thing. What do you think about it?
Cause I, I it makes me feel weird. I don't
like it. It's misguided. I Love Greg,
but I think it's misguided for folks who
don't know what we're talking about. Uh,
Greg is decided to start stealing
bill Cosby's material and uh,
doing it openly.
So he does these classic Bill Cosby bits
and then he lets everybody know in the
middle of it that he's stealing bill
Cosby's bits to take away from him what is
most precious. But it doesn't
really work because it doesn't,
you don't like if someone tries to
steal some shit off of like shiny,
happy Jihad or something like that, like
it's already out. It's already on CD.
I did it and you know,
fucking 2006 like if you're stealing,
you're not taking anything away from
me, you're just, you're just, you know,
you're just selling
yourself short by stealing.
So like if Greg does bill
Cosby's material, you don't
ever take it away from him.
It's already recorded. These are like,
he doesn't even do that material anymore.
So I don't know. I don't think
it's really, it's active.
It seems like you're taking something
negative and being negative about it.
It just doesn't seem it. And I also think
it just opens the door to people go,
well Greg stolen bill Cosby's
jokes, you know, and Ah,
but he says it on stage that stealing it.
He lets people know in the middle of
it that he's stealing bill Cosby's.
Greg Fitzsimmons steals bill
Cosby's bits now he does.
He's doing it on purpose to try
to take something from bill Cosby.
Like this is the idea behind it.
I think
it sounds like Dell ocozzio it'd be super
psyched on that because it's like, wow,
I'm getting credit for being funny
and it's distracting people from,
there's actually something totally
bill Cosby. Thanks. Totally true.
That's completely defeating.
Yeah, I think it's a gimmick. I
mean, I, I see what he's like.
He's just genuinely thinks
the guy's disgusting. Right?
Jan [inaudible] glorify it.
His comedy by,
Yeah. I mean, I don't get it either.
I don't know. I just, I don't know.
Maybe if I had them on and Greg, oh, have
monsoon and he's going to be on soon.
I guess we're talking about doing
something with the next couple of weeks,
so maybe he'll explain it better.
I just,
I wouldn't want to have anything
to do with it. You know,
there's some fascinating,
there's some lady that was on who was a
legal expert who was discussing it and
she said he might be the most
prolific serial rapist in history,
which is fucking insane. It's insane
to look at it that way. This guy,
Mr Huxtable,
you know the fucking guy from the TV show,
the guy who had the squeaky clean comedy,
the guy who did the bit about, you know,
the football players saying
hi mom to his son on TV.
This guy who was like wholesome
Mister America in a sweater.
But none of these girls like
the next morning, well guide,
what the fuck happened?
He raped me, I am going to do the
police and this is all you know,
kind of like wishy washy.
Like yeah I kind of felt weird that
night but no one really went right to the
police though.
Did they?
Um, I don't know. I don't
know. It seems weird.
It just seems like to me it seems
like a lot of people just kind of,
I don't know. Well listen man, if you
were a girl, okay look at it this way.
You're some young girl who's trying to
make it in show business and you're,
you know, you get brought into his
office because you know his, you know,
he knows your parents or something like
that. That was a lot of the situation.
Like he,
there was one of one situation was
there was like a modeling company and he
would contact the mall and
company to get people on his show.
Like you're looking to cast roles that
didn't even exist and he'd have them in
his office and drug them and fuck on cass.
He would bring them into his
office and drug them like,
would you like a Cappuccino? What'd
you learn to do the carpet? You know,
and give them a Cappuccino and fuck them.
I mean, just drug them. I don't know
where to happen though. Like four
hours later, this girl's like,
I just went there for an interview,
had a Cappuccino and he fucked me.
Like you'd go, right? Yeah.
This is why. This is why. No,
because I think for what I was
going to say is like these,
these are young girls that are probably
completely overwhelmed that they're even
in his presence. Like they can't even
believe that they're meaning bill Cosby.
So you're insanely starstruck and the
fact that he's touching you puts you into
a state of shock.
Like you're fucked up and then you're
confused because you wake up and you're,
you were drugged.
You don't know what happened and then
you're embarrassed and horrified of it.
I mean, there's so many Mr Huxtable.
Exactly. It's like he's, this is
before the Internet, man. You know,
if a girl like that,
if that happened today,
a girl go on our Facebook page and say,
today I went on an audition with bill
Cosby and he drug me and rape me.
And like, Whoa, like Bam, that takes off
and it goes viral. But back then, man,
if you go to the fucking police,
they might not say shit or they might
go to cosmic cosmic might sue you.
But you've got to realize some women did.
And in 2005 he actually
paid off women and he,
that's why this all got more serious
lately is because they released the
transcripts and the transcripts said
that he admitted that he had drug these
girls, he admitted it. So this,
this did go to cops and it
didn't go out to the public.
So it's like, it's not kinda weird,
it's just the amount of power and money.
This guy bill Cosby, he's
like a billionaire. I mean,
the amount of money
that guy has is insane.
And the amount of power that kind of
money has where you're talking about just
teams of lawyers that just try to figure
out any sort of attack that they could
do to try to mitigate any of the issues
that are going on with people accusing
him of all this crazy,
you know, rape shit.
It's like he, he, he
fought it for a long time.
He hasn't really publicly denied any
of it. No, he hasn't denied it at all.
He hasn't denied it all. He just
doesn't talk about it. You know,
one of the weirdest things that he said,
he did this one interview and he said,
in all my years of show business,
I've never seen anything like this.
Yeah,
well that's called free speech.
This is what's going on now.
[inaudible] everyone can talk now.
Like now people can get online and
talk about crimes that you committed.
It's like you can't hide behind lawyers
anymore. You can't threaten them.
You know, you can't, you and your girl
and you're barely paying your bills.
You know,
you're barely getting by and he offers
you $20,000 or $100,000 to shut the fuck
up and you have to sign
some written agreement.
It says you never speak about this again.
You take that money.
That's what they do.
And that's what they did in 2005 and
I don't know how much they got paid.
It's probably even more than that.
Probably a million. I mean, when you,
when you're worth what that
guy's made in his career, I mean,
who knows what he's got left. But when
someone 100,000 here, 100,000 there,
for a guy like that, there's nothing.
He could silence a lot of shit.
But just keeping people quiet with money,
you know?
And that's probably what happened when
things came up. I mean, I don't know.
And then there's also people feet with
fear of being blackballed, you know,
being blackballed from show business when
you're a struggling actress and you're
barely getting by.
The difference between bill Cosby talking
badly about you and accusing you of
being a liar. Like, who's going to listen
to you and who's going to listen to him?
They got to think that most people are
going to listen to bill Cosby and that
could wreck your career before it ever
gets started. Just sink your ship.
And it seems like a lot of
these girls that he preyed on,
we're trying to make it in show business.
There was a big part of
like what he would attack.
He would go after these girls that were
trying to become actresses and he was
like a mentor figure. That was like
the angle that he was presenting.
It's dark shit man.
How'd we get on that?
I take one pice. Oh, we're
talking about Greg Fitzsimmons,
Greg Fitzsimmons in his bill Cosby a
strategy. I just, yeah, I don't know.
It's a little misguided I think. I Dunno.
Maybe. Maybe Greg's got a better point.
Maybe we need to let him articulate it.
It's the darkest thing in
all of the history of standup
comedy, I think. I mean,
or, or close to it, you know?
I mean, what else there,
that Vince Champ guy that was raping
college girls and he got caught,
he would say horrible shit to them.
Like pray for me and stuff
like while he's fucking them.
Well that guy's in jail
for the rest of his life.
Cosby's just out running around.
I mean,
it doesn't seem like there's any charges
that are being put up against him.
And as far as I know,
there's only one woman that the rape
happened inside the statue of limitations.
I don't know what the
statute of limitations is,
but I think it's like six or seven.
That's it. That seems fucked.
I think it's rape. I think it's seven
years. But that's kind of like whoa.
You know, it's a little wishy
washy. Meaning like if you've,
if you've raped somebody and you
have great proof eight years later,
I'm sure there's still going now. I don't
know. I don't think that's the case.
I think a statute of limitations is
pretty rock solid. Like once it, yeah,
like double jeopardy and shit. Yeah,
it's not, it's law, you know? I Dunno.
It's fucked up. We've talked
about that so many times. It's a,
it's a subject has been beaten to death,
but if it seems like it's so significant
that you kind of have to beat it to
death cause it's hard to believe.
Imagine if that was like your dad or
something like that. Imagine, you know,
if you found out your dad was a
fucking serial rapist or your mom,
even your mom's drug and dude
suck in their dicks taking it
their shoes
as size side do about if your
son came up from school and told,
told you that his teachers sucked
his Dick, I piss you would be,
don't you ever ruin that?
Knows that he called the cops.
It was called the police
because a teacher is like,
how does someone ever find out
that a female teacher, Melissa Kid,
one of those policies as an open
his mouth? Like where was his dad?
My son did that out. I wouldn't be
pissed to believe, dude, you're fine.
Okay. It's just, there's
a giant difference.
Chino woman molesting a boy and a
man molesting a girl. I mean, I,
I don't think it should be encouraged,
but it's certainly not the same.
Did you hear about anonymous? A releasing
all the KKK members information?
Supposedly there's a lot of
us senators got released.
I applaud you anonymous.
I feel like anonymous
overall across the board does more
good shit. I don't, I hear very,
very few bad accusations on their part.
Almost everything they do.
I agree with. I love it.
Like it. Good fuck the KKK.
Fuck all those crazy fucking stone age
assholes who give a shit about the origin
of birth of your great, great,
great grandparents. You know,
you're not Peul not
off the pool of rights.
It's going to be interesting though,
cause supposedly there's some Ferguson
police that are involved in this side and
it, the whole list, uh,
officially gets released and I
think next week or this week,
meanwhile, Brian's on it. Well,
they could just put your name on it,
man. If somebody wanted to fuck with you,
Steve o's in the KKK.
What?
Yeah, you, you've, you've kind of
morphed. It's really fascinating.
I mean seeing you go from being this wild,
crazy ketamine,
Norton psychopath,
jumping off roofs and shit and damaging
your body to be in this Vegan who's
trying to live a kind life and trying to
be nice to people and you don't want to
randomly hook up with girls cause you
want to have a meaningful relationship and
taking care of animals and fuck seaworld.
It's really amazing to
see you, uh, become this.
Yeah. You know, I mean,
every once in a while I
got to do something pretty
fucked up just to make sure
that I'm, I'm not a pussy. Well,
I didn't meet you until you were sober.
Right. You know, I missed the crazy train.
I've kept it pretty crazy
sober too though. Yeah. Oh
No, no doubt. Yeah. I mean,
just explaining what you're planning on
doing it the paramount before they found
out about it. Do you think
there's going to be a jackass,
jackass four k or something
like that, ma'am. But, um,
everyone was getting old and her fucking
injury last one was so great work and
I'm working my dick opt to get
my own movie. Oh yeah, yeah.
Like a sort of,
sort of like the bad grandpa format.
But I was bad grandpa. Good.
Oh yeah. That was a funny,
funny fucking mood. I cried when he
got his dick stuck in that machine.
Oh my God.
It was one of the funny,
and that was a funny fucking
movie that I was really good.
I don't think dot enough credit.
I really don't think it got as much credit
as it deserved. I think it did well.
I was never one, but it's one of the
funniest movies I've ever seen in my life.
And when you talk about
like funny all time movies,
very few people bring up bad grandpa.
I think they should.
I think it's a God damn epic movie
Kid shitting on the wall and when he's
dancing and dancing that kids awesome.
I love the kid in there when,
when he goes to the, the
black club and he's, uh,
w with all the ladies and he's
dancing. Come on. Fuck. Yeah, Dude.
It's fucking epic moving.
Yeah.
So do you have a movie of it worked out
or do you have an idea? Yeah, I, I'm,
I'm gonna, I'm gonna like keep the cards
close to your chest. I did, but um,
I, but I got to deal with that. You
got a big time movie producer guys.
Yeah.
So Noward and like God and taking it
and like getting it written and get the
director and then take it to
the studio is kind of a deal.
So we were talking about this, the
damage that it's done early, the fuck on,
but we were talking about the damage
you've done to your body before you went
off to pee. And you said
Esophagus. Esophagus.
Barrett's Barrett's esophagus. I
had, but that's it. Other than that,
like pretty much hands and joints and back
and joints are all good. That's crazy.
What about Knoxville's? He, okay. He's
gotten some back issues. I think
it's tough from that bowl. I,
which bull bull you,
he went blind fold
and the
right now as I bought was a
Yak, but oh, that was a dad.
I don't think that he got particular
herd on that. I think that one thing,
one thing that, uh, did a lot of
damage to him was early, early on,
uh,
dropping in on the skateboard half pipe,
one of the big vert ramps and just like,
I mean just fell straight
to the flat bottom.
And like I remember like
hearing that like, you know,
if he turns his like
turning the car like hurts,
you know how to host
his shoulder's fucked.
Definitely did more
damage because like he,
he didn't have like the benefit of
growing up like falling off a skateboard,
sort of learning how to fall down.
They get out of like,
when he like got a lot of
us are like Sorta, you know,
I mean I'm like,
you know,
sort of circus clown acrobat
lifelong fuck by trade.
So yeah. So yeah. So I'm
kind of more like, like a,
I'm better at falling down to
that getting hurt. My falls down.
It just me hitting the ground in the
worst way, which is why it's shit.
It's always the best,
you know.
Oh yeah, that makes sense. Cause you
can do flips and all that shit. Right.
You fall with your body.
Yeah. And I'm, I'm more like a cat when
it gets down to it and Knoxville is just,
you know, say I think that he's,
he's probably in worse shape,
but then again the same time I
think that, uh, you know, had he,
it takes good care of him sobbing,
you know,
and I think maybe he's done some mending
or get some disc issues. I don't know.
Yeah, I've had a gang
of those. I did, um, uh,
my own stunts for this accidentally did
my own stunts for this Kevin James Movie.
I was in it because I suck at
riding bikes. I had a ride,
a bike and I had hit him with a flag.
Which Kevin James Movie.
It was a zookeeper and I was
guy that I'm telling you about is
the one I did that movie. Which guy?
Todd Garner.
Oh, the guy who the produce. I know
Todd. He's a good dude. I love Todd. Um,
so I,
I had to hit the break walls.
I was like riding a bike and I
was hitting him with his flag,
but I'm hitting the front brake. And when
you, you know, you hit the front brake,
if it locks, you go flying over the top.
And I did it like three times the skin.
We wind up using that in the movie instead
of the stunt man because I just want
to go fucking flying.
But I'm pretty good at following.
It was a lifelong martial
artists. So all the, like the,
I knew when I hit the ground that
you can't just hit the ground.
You got to kind of like roll with
it. Sure. But, uh, you really have a,
a real strong appreciation for stunt
people when you do something like that.
Because I go, well, I got through
this, luckily without getting hurt,
but if I had to do this every
fucking day or every week,
some new thing where you fallen off of
a building or jumping off of a fucking
moving car, I did potential for
damaging yourself as super high.
Or you hear about those people dying.
It's always like some movie that no one's
going to give a fuck about some racing
motorcycle scene, a Steven Seagal movie
and someone dies. You know, I mean,
you gotta when you watch those crazy
action movies, think about that.
Appreciate the fact that those people,
they literally put their physical health
and their life on the line for your
entertainment.
You know,
I didn't think about it too much until
I just fucked up and fell a few times on
a bike in a movie.
You know,
it's like those guys do it
on purpose all the time.
Yeah, that's right, man.
It's fucking hard Gig, man.
That's a hard drive.
Said the fucking paramount.
See this now? I want to be,
there you go. Why don't you
go? Yeah, yeah. There you go.
No one's holding you back then.
All Right, ladies and gentlemen, let's
wrap this bitch up. Steve. Oh, Steve. Oh,
on Twitter. Um, paramount
theater. November 21st
Austin, Texas, Austin,
Texas. Uh, I will be
in Denver at that time.
I'm at the Belko theater on November
21st with the Great Ian Edwards and then,
um,
March 20th Edwards epic, uh, in
Madison, Wisconsin on the 20th.
Uh,
all that shit is on my website.
Joe rogan.net and the tourist section.
Brian, we got going on a Wednesday.
We're at the comedy store.
Me and you, a secret show.
And also me and Tony and
slid a secret guests. Yeah.
It's some secret guys there really
problems with Bosh, hopefully,
and awesome me,
Antonio bringing kill Tony to Pittsburgh
in Ohio thanksgiving week. Uh, it's, uh,
November 27th we'll be in Pittsburgh
and November 29th in Ohio.
Good to test squad.tv. Click on
tour days. Alright, you fucks a,
I've got a podcast in one hour with Chris
Ryan, so I'll see you then. Bye. Bye.
Big Kiss.
Thanks Joe.
Yeah.